Oh shit You forgot Give me a sec Hello everybody What a
great way to start this stream Hello I forgot to have my app
open I was like I was like I'm ready I'm so ready Good
morning Oh shit the overlap of rival music and also my BGM.
Oh, not yet.
The sponsored portion has not started yet.
We still have time.
There's still time, guys.
I have a technically 12-minute buffer.
Oh, wait, what's math?
No, it's not 12 minutes.
13 minutes.
Sorry, I'm mapping Six minute Six minute buffer Map is so
hard Sorry, I was like counting in my head How much?
Six minute buffer Before the sponsored Stream time It's so,
that map is so hard Numbers, guys Numbers am I right?
oh hello everybody hello hello as always today is marvel
rivals day huge shout out to marvel rivals for sponsoring oh
shit it is because i was recording stuff sorry it's rivals
day there you go now i should sound now i should sound
better now all right god wait the settings were at that the
entire oh my god sorry i just i just realized i was also my
settings were lower than it should be anyway hello hello
everybody hello everyone um where was i did i tweet out the
stream i should have did i yes i did oh my god i'm like
second doubting myself on everything i don't even like
believe in myself anymore i
anyway i'm professional i don't know everyone hello but
yesterday is rival's day we still five minutes so we have to
uh we go straight into it afelia thank you for the five
gifted subs thank you thank you uh he tweeted it three
minutes i i didn't even believe in myself Someone was like,
did you tweet it?
I was like, did I?
I was like, I thought I did.
But I don't know anymore.
I don't know anymore.
I don't believe in myself.
I actually have to like check on social, like check on
Twitter just to be sure.
Just to be sure.
Anyway, yes, it is Arrivals Day, which means, which means
it's early access.
for season 7.5 I have to also like double check too because
it's been so many seasons that I don't even I've lost count
where we were at I I've lost count where we were at and uh
for season 7.5 uh it is black cat yes uh she is a dps and
wow wow How's up?
And damn, does she DP that ass?
Sorry, I still have three more minutes so the sponsored
stream starts.
I still have three more minutes.
Oh, I got to get it out of my system.
And you guys are like, what the fuck are you talking about,
Doki?
You'll see, you'll see, I didn't get to practice, I didn't
get to, like, not only practice is the right word, but I
actually, like, try to see what is, uh, what is up with her,
but I saw bits of the video, and she looks very scary.
She does look very intense as a DPS.
Um, she basically is like, she plays like, she looks like a
Black Panther type of character, uh, with a focus on, like,
you know, and stuff but like more but does more mobility has
more mobility and I was like how do you have more mobility
but that's what I see from the videos Sierra thank you for
the hundred biddies thank you thank you um but yes uh huge
shout out to Marvel Rivals for today's sponsor um you guys
want to support the stream support Marvel Rivals feel free
to click on the link pinned in the chat or on the panels
below.
It does help out a lot.
But yes, please.
Feel free to join me and play Marvel Rivals for free right
now.
Yay!
Alright.
Anyway.
Other than that, I think...
I'm trying to remember what else...
What other new things...
Is implemented for this season?
Or not this season.
For next season.
um it's like i know they they change oh yeah luna snow is
completely busted out what i've read it's back to luna snow
you never escape from luna snow yeah apparently she has just
like who is it i was reading someone saying that um she is
just three damage lower than hella uh for her primary as a
support character and i was like how is she how is she that
close in dps to ella yeah but better than ella because her
yeah she has better util yeah none of us thank you for the
20 gifted chips thank you thank you um so she technically is
like a better ella right now like with her new uh new buffs
because they buffed her damage and your heals, I believe.
So her primary is like just a little bit weaker than Hella.
But people are like, you might as well just play.
Yeah, it's basically Hella that can heal.
So Flake Luna is back, baby.
Also, I'll need you guys help.
And I need you guys to help me because I don't know what
they've changed.
I didn't read the patch notes today.
Oh, shit, it's time.
Ding, ding, ding.
It's time, everybody.
Ding ding ding ding hello all right so it's time to show you
guys black cat welcome to season 7.5 early access ding ding
ding ding it's preview time preview hours um so i need you
guys to help me read about what what are the biggest changes
for the other characters i just know about um black cat uh
all right so obviously first off we gotta go that cost me
yeah oh did you guys see that video of some cat with some
disease that makes his voice super fucking low and you're
like how low can it get oh so look oh my god is that a
middle gear reference anyway and then and then like the cat
was like me y'all and i was like wait does that's That's
just Mugenic.
I was just like, wait, I've heard that voice before.
I was like, oh my God, wait, I've heard that meow before.
It was from Mugenic.
It's like, meow.
It's like a literally cat that has like a fucking vocal
disorder.
That's just Mews like that.
Anyway, let's go buy that.
Parker's disguise and he's like his number one fanboy Peter
Parker the photographer wait I need to buy myself that not
like I'm going to be playing maybe I am there might be a
mode where I have to play Spider-Man I've never touched this
character before anyway me yeah oh yeah oh my god I'm quick
how foolish of me I forgot because I'm so tired.
Meow.
Anyway, there's...
There is a black cat.
There she is.
Look at her go.
That's damn.
Oh, yeah.
I thought this was really funny.
I saw the preview of this.
And then someone was like, why is he drinking hot milk?
hot milk with his cereal i was like peter why are you why
are you riding a bike with hot milk as cereal why is it
cereal god damn weirdo is that oatmeal i thought it was
cereal no i'm pretty sure that's cereal i saw i saw some
loops in there because he's spider-man
there he is there she is then oh my gosh she has a cat as
her e-moombo that's cute oh my imagine imagine you die to
her and she starts petting her cat all right okay where was
that all right so yeah those are the new the new cosmetics i
believe this is also new i believe You guys can You guys can
correct me if I'm wrong But I believe this is also new New
blade skin Yippica, yeah I fucking love their cosmetics Oh
my god Get it, get down Blade!
Get down!
Come on!
God, go to the hood Down before you kill those vampires all
right let's wait is this also new is a silo wait what's this
okay is a silo also new oh yeah she's playing dennis she
still got a dance
all right yeah i believe that is also new as well where the
silo skin but let's look at this
I just know I know she does like her her moves are like
currency-based four stars.
All right, let's see if I can retain anything All right, I
guess we're gonna learn live I guess we're gonna Yeah, so
apparently she learns her movesets are money-based which is
like perfect for me in general Oh wait All right, get out of
here.
Meow.
Oh my god, wait, is that her default?
Wait, I forgot to check one more thing.
I never forgot something.
What is her cosmetic?
All right, oh, so, oh yeah, this is her alternative for
those who are...
Oh, holy shit, okay.
Oh my god, she surprises me every day.
every I'm always surprised I actually went in very blind I
went oh my god all right anyway back back to black cat all
right let's read guys it's time for a favorite part of the
game reading all right feline fairy swipe forward with razor
sharp Oh, god damn.
Oh, no.
There's a fortune part of her ability.
Okay.
Alright, I was not ready.
Oh, god damn.
There's three tabs.
There's three pages worth of this.
Oh, no.
I love Cabin.
Alright, our passive is a gift of gold.
Black cat shares her luck over allies when white fox
embraces her newfound fortune she unleases tracking okay so
she's the anchor so basically she gives white fox um her
mortal enemy um and captain america uh while damaging and
slowing foes oh my gosh wait that's pretty it's pretty
strong and then shield block raise pads and allows him to
aim direct deflect the projectile directly oh so he can aim
the projectiles this time Oh, yeah, like, it makes Captain
America a shield tank.
None, thank you for Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, calling.
Okay, this is our default.
Calling card.
Issue a calling card to all enemies.
Inslee dashes to any enemy in sight and range.
Tear to them over your claws to deal percentage damage.
Okay, and her alt stays the same.
All right.
At least we know her alt stays the same.
Her alt stays the same.
Does everything else...
Alright, her shift stays the same.
Lunge forward claws.
Baird slicing through any enemies caught in your path.
Launch a grappling hook forward.
Damages an enemy on impact and steals fortune.
Okay.
Performs a double jump.
Alright, so she has a double jump.
This will be in the exam.
Guys, this will be in the exam.
Spend fortune to unleash either claw whip or phantom
pursuit.
Okay, so right click, right click activates her, whatever
the fuck these two are.
So let's look at her default stuff before, oh my gosh, me.
Oh my god, like, my god, okay.
I'm sorry, I am a professional.
So that's me stealing, yoying, God, it's payday time.
I know, like, bye.
Holy me!
Yeah!
It's painted!
Alright.
And this is like a... I think this is like a Black Panther
Dash.
It like feels like it.
I have two of that.
So that's the Black Panther Dash.
Oh, I knew I forgot to bind stuff.
Wait.
I need to bind my melee real quick.
Alright.
Uh...
Melee...
And then that's it.
That's really it.
I mean, for melee...
Check if it resets on kill.
Ooh, that's smart.
That's a dive player right there.
It does not reset.
I have two of these.
I have two of them and it does not reset.
All right, and then E.
What was E again?
I already forgot everything.
This is on the exam already forgot.
All right, launches, grappling hook forward.
And then, okay, this launches.
Oh yeah, by the way, here's the double jump.
Luckily, the double jump has no cooldown.
All right, this is a five second cooldown, by the way.
So I just...
How far is this range?
Yoink!
Hey, did it.
All right.
Let's see.
Just press F1.
Oh my gosh.
That's a lot smarter.
All right.
Wait, where is that range?
How big is the hitbox?
It's not that big.
You have to actually be on it.
All right, let's just...
New ability cooldowns real quick, because I want to know how
far.
All right, there you go.
That's the range.
Whatever that is.
Whatever that is, is the range.
Yoink.
By the way, this is no cooldown.
Anyway, it's not like I can keep robbing you.
All right, and then F.
What was F again?
F is...
Where's the F key?
Wait.
Okay, invisible state.
Okay, F isn't what?
Okay, F I get to buy.
We're...
Okay, open it.
Okay, I buy...
Oh, my God.
I...
All right.
The default is invisible mode, but I can buy...
Okay, I gotta know what any of all of these do.
Okay.
All right.
You're in the...
You have one second to make your decision.
There are two, four, there are six character buttons.
There are six choices.
There's six choices.
You're in a 1v1.
There are one second to make your choice.
You're in a three, don't you read?
I don't know.
What did I buy?
What did I fucking buy?
I...
dude we gotta stop fighting guys guys stop time out i need
to buy stuff real quick what the fuck did i buy what did i i
get you quick five okay let me let me read up what i can buy
okay um okay tablet of destiny um gain a random amount of
fortune oh my god enter an abysmal state set duration.
Yo, pause, pause.
I gotta shop real quick, guys.
Okay.
Conjure an orb of mythical faulty flame to Riva and mark all
nearby enemies.
Purify yourself.
Insulin removing any active control effects.
The ring of Zona.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I need a... Okay, I have to Remember, okay, I need to
remember these icons.
All right, okay, this goes invisible.
So stealthy.
This does not go invisible.
Oh, this goes, I bought it.
Okay, okay, luckily, when you buy it, you can buy it in
advance.
So like, you know, five seconds before the fight, you buy
something.
And then like, and then you just press F again to active.
That actually is a lot better.
There is no cooldown.
Your cooldown is how much money you have.
That's your cooldown.
Okay, that's a lot better.
It would be awkward if we're like in the middle of a fight
and then you have to buy something
Okay, that's a lot better.
All right, so the cool there's no cool down for buying For
buy I think it's gonna take a while for people to know how
to play here because it's taking a while to read out a
player
It's taking me a while to read to read Read about it.
So, I need to remember what she has.
Okay.
Purify.
Yes, but when I buy these items, I forgot what they do.
All right.
So, the crystal.
Let me disappear real quick.
Let me, so you guys can read along with me.
Open a portal on the surface.
Oh, I saw that.
The ring.
It's like the portal thing.
It's like the magic portal.
But like better because it actually goes through walls this
time.
Creates a hypnosis field.
Disables movements and grounds all enemies caught.
Okay, fish, portal, crown are the most important for me.
But because like the other ones, it's like you like buy it
in advance because you're like, oh, they have like all the
cooldowns.
You have to buy the crystal to remove all the cooldowns.
Active control.
Yeah, you're like, oh, before I have to go to fight, I have
to buy this.
go in and dive at least i can use that in case they use
cooldown on me and then what if i guess i don't know i guess
like destiny's is just gamba it's like all in all in on the
gamba um okay all right luckily luckily i don't have to
process as much as i all right so this oh my god wait how
long does this lap that lasts for a long time i feel like
does that not last for a long time all right all right
thousand dollars all right there's the fish the destiny is
the portal so let's test this portal out that was the money
gamba the gamma sorry the portal is this and then ah I see
no okay wait the range is pretty nice wait this range is
pretty oh it's sorry my I intuitively went to gamble it was
just it was just instinct I was like I had to Alright, this
marks people.
Oh, I see.
But it just marks one person.
Is that useful?
I get...
Wait, does it only mark one person?
Yeah.
Okay.
I guess you use it.
Wait, how long does it last for?
I guess if you're protecting your...
I guess protecting your support flanks?
Oh!
Oh, it's...
It's here.
no it doesn't kill anyone it just reveals them oh it's it's
just here it's just oh it's just it's just here now okay i
wonder if you can kill it i actually am can you kill this
i'm pretty sure you can right yeah it seems like it feels
like you can kill him so you just put there to i guess like
help your support you know if your support needs help Wait,
let's see if I actually...
Pigaboo!
Goodbye.
No, you can't put it in mid.
Yeah, it's a laser.
It's gone.
He's in space now.
Yeah.
You killed it out.
Goodbye.
There it goes.
And this was the cleanse.
Okay, I'm processing it.
Wait, no.
Or was it?
this the cleanse?
Wait, what was what again?
I almost figured it all out.
Okay.
Purify it.
Okay, yeah, the crystal is the cleanse.
The crystal is the cleanse.
There you go.
So if I get cooled down.
Oh, it farms money!
Let's go!
Wait, if... Wait, that's... Wait, it farms money.
I'm rich forever!
You must be able to destroy it.
There's no way.
I think you can destroy it because you can farm this is an
infinite money glitch this yeah it's an amk farm this is
literally an infinite money glitch you must you must be able
to destroy it there's no way and we'll we'll see we're gonna
see okay yeah you're right let me put it right here there
has to be able to destroy there's no way oh no it's just all
right oh no it does it does okay thank god it does guys it
does get destroyed it does get destroyed guys so how did it
there we go alright it does yeah oh it can die it can die it
can die but i think it's mostly used just so like you know
what time is it okay i said 10 more minutes i was like so
that like you can use it to help your supports if there's a
flanker behind or something because like because it's just a
laser it's like a laser pointer and being like there's an
enemy right behind us or something and then when it dies
then you know there's an enemy behind you if the pointer the
laser pointer dies because you know then you'll be like oh
someone pointer uh someone destroys my laser pointer be
careful of your flank that's the only thing i could think of
of the use for it can it point at invisible when she's
invisible well i can't really well let's see that well let's
see if invisible woman goes invisible here
gonna say it how do i test that by myself all right does she
go invisible if she stands there
anytime now well i don't i don't think she does
come on do something invisible women do something Whoops I
don't think she does go invisible Well I don't know if I I
think I like the deed I don't know I think I'm I think I
like the default I like the meow I don't know if that's it
But for some reason The default's calling for me Right now
For some reason I'm not safe Oh, yeah, there is one more I
forgot to check out.
Okay, this move, whatever the claw whip was.
Oh, oh, okay, the claw, okay, hold space to crawl.
Oh, yeah, I can crawl.
Plowing jinx, the enemy is on hit.
Hit jinx, what was the chance to lose your bonus damage when
striking black cat with a critical hit?
Okay, so I forgot that she can climb.
All right, what's her whip?
And whip them forward.
All right, okay, so a...
Apparently, um, okay, what that dash unleashes?
Okay, I have a new E with my right click.
Relish a rapid and flash back to your starting position.
Is untargetable during this.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
What's the difference?
Okay, wait, but I need to know.
what is the difference between using weapon for dealing
damage to all enemies caught in range oh i see it okay it
costs money that makes sense i was gonna say everything
costs except okay the claw whip causes money but but if you
use the
use fandom pursuit oh they both cost money everything just
costs money Economy in this economy.
Damn.
All right.
All right, black cat.
All right, so I wanted to see this.
What does this do?
Oh shit, not that.
Am I healing?
Is it working?
I assume it's working.
I It's just a lot.
It's just the short cool down.
All right.
See.
Apparently I'll slow him down.
Oh, okay.
Yep, it does do it.
All right.
It's just one click, honestly.
It's not like...
Not like too hard.
It's just one.
Yeah.
It's just one click.
Okay.
She releases tracking spirit tails to grab healing and speed
while damaging.
just do it like here like the range is not that far though
yeah it's like here so you have to be around me there i have
to like so it heals speeds and damages and slows the other
enemy team that's basically it uh your partner fire bounces
more too well but She unleashes tracking to grant and smile
damaging.
Oh, I can't try that on.
Whoops, sorry.
Alright.
What's the Captain America?
Her allows him to aim direct.
Okay, I can aim it.
Alright, here we go.
Is it...
Am I aiming it?
Oh, wait.
X.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Whoa.
That is a lot bigger.
Damn.
Okay.
I did not expect...
Oh my god.
Wow.
That's double the size.
The money shield.
That's actually a significant difference of size.
Okay.
Oh my god, Captain America.
How could you?
You started doping.
Oh my god, you used performance enhancements, Captain
America.
What about liberty?
He's overdosing in freedom right now.
All right, I believe that is All the new stuff, we have five
more minutes to check out any other updates.
What's her?
Oh, my God.
You're right.
Her all the most.
What did I do?
Okay.
The one thing I forgot of instantly dashed at any enemy
insight tearing into them.
I know it.
instantly dash to them wait what oh wait
oh okay
you just dash into oh does it reset oh wait resets
oh meow i know right meow So it resets after every...
Alright, so that's her up.
So basically she can reset it after every kill.
But it's still like...
I don't think she does more damage though, does she?
Does it seem like it?
Is she a Carlycar instantly dash to your enemy?
Tearing to them where you're...
Oh, to dance percentage damage.
So it's like Wolverine.
Okay.
Oh, it's like Wolverine then.
So...
Yeah.
So she's gonna- she'd be really good.
Like her- all is like Bucky-esque with the fact that it
resets and everything.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, I forgot about the crawling part.
Neat.
Oh.
You can't crawl back afterwards.
You can only crawl one time.
Yeah, if you get off the wall once, it's like, that's it.
Because you can like, Reclimb the wall.
You have to...
If you jump it, wait.
Yeah.
You can't recline the wall.
If you let go, you just can't climb it.
It's just climb.
That's it.
You have only one chance to climb.
You can.
You don't have to touch the ground to climb it.
You can, like, do something where you're here and then climb
to the other wall and then start climbing.
You just can't recline it.
You can't reset the climb.
That's basically it.
It might be...
She's still pretty easy to kill, though, in her ult.
I feel like.
Unless... I guess...
You have to know the combo.
I don't know the combo.
I'm just slashing.
I think, like... I think if you know the combo, then like...
I think you can do a lot with it.
But I don't know the combo.
I'm just...
I'm just smashing buttons.
Meow.
She gets like over health but she doesn't regain more over
health though it seems like all right It's almost yeah, you
might need it.
Yeah, you might need it.
You definitely need a flank a lot with her All right, let me
look at check this real quick to see if I'm not all right,
I'm not getting tagged So I'm not late.
All right.
Let me reset my I gotta get ready.
It's almost time one minute left One minute left till the
the creator games.
All right, let me reset my discord so I've pushed the mute
Oh wait, it's my sound team here?
Sound team!
Are you guys here?
It's time to do our, play our favorite game.
Oh yeah, the Luna changes.
I mean, it's just, she's just a lot stronger.
Like...
Okay.
No, she's literally just Ella.
Two shots and shots.
Okay.
If you play Flake Luna, congratulations, it's your time.
And she has, it's like, Flake Luna, like...
What the fuck is this damage?
That's why I'm saying her.
She's back, guys!
She's back!
It's like she never...
It's time.
It's like she never left.
Alright, let me...
Let me make sure I have...
Everything set up.
I need my key buttons and everything for push to mute.
Season zero Luna.
It's like she never left, guys.
I knew she'd always come back.
She always finds her way back, guys.
Were she still...
Alright, well, to be fair, the reason why she has one of the
worst win rate right now is because she's not meta anymore.
But I'm pretty sure this makes her meta again.
They nerfed Cloak and Dagger's Alt I don't know if that's
gonna make much impact But like, Cloak and Dagger's Alt is
nerfed now And I think Luna would A good Luna would make a
huge impact If she actually, if she doesn't heal bot Because
there's no reason to heal bot right now When she fucking
does this If she does this There's no reason to heal bot I
think we're gonna see a lot of flanking Luna's now like
dpsing um like a mantis i feel like this is just like if
you're a mantis player you might as well just play luna
because you just do more all right but yeah anyway let me
double check no one's in there it's just two people in there
but it's but it's time though it's 2 30.
like all right let me let me see if anybody's maybe they're
in the lobby maybe they're in the in the lobby right now all
right let's see uh is there any new battle passes i haven't
shown you guys i think these were all these were all in
already i'm pretty sure oh if i have to give me a sec if i
have okay i might as well just get a luna skin and worry if
i get to play luna here oh let's see does she have a new
battle pass skin i'll just buy it just for naked naked adam
just just for naked adam oh yeah sound team if you're here
message me about sound balancing
all right i'm just gonna buy till where's naked adam where
is he there he is all right there we go if i have to play
adam at least i'm playing his best skin at least i'm at
least i'm playing his best if I have to.
Oh, yeah, wait.
I gotta grab them.
K-pop Luna.
Alright, there we go.
There was a Luna.
I get skin I can use.
Oh, and then Loki.
Oh, God.
That's called perfection.
That is the peak human body right there.
The perfect human.
Alright, custom game.
Which one is the survival to join it is black cat joins
black cat joins there you go and i'm on lay not last lot not
last yeah no adams can can top this now yeah i know why the
fuck are we at frankfurt i was i was gonna be like excuse me
um this is not ignited right now this is excuse me i do not
want to reopen the ignite conversation about servers
like i'm down for west coast east coast but not frankfort as
a west coast player please have mercy on me that was a
hundred t i don't remember i think it was was a hundred t
versus fly quest i'm pretty i think that was yeah it was it
was under these versus fly quest
all right but yes sound team get ready for sound balancing
i'm joining the vc right now but i muted myself because i'm
very shy and i don't do well in social interactions all
right let's see what is the server call i'm just setting up
i'm setting up the vc stuff um What is a server called
Marvel Rivals?
Of course, it's called Marvel Rivals, but which I have so
many servers.
Yes, he's adding a little bit too much.
Preview stream.
What team am I on?
Team A.
Yay.
Am I not on the right?
Team A, VC.
Why is it not popping up as it should?
bump bump bump all right let's see i'm setting up the voice
chat not the last person in the lobby though i'm in the vc
and i'm also the only person on my team that's in the lobby
no it's like the um i used the stream kit overlay uh for
like the voice chat overlay stuff so i'm just setting that
up right now and it doesn't show you like folders or
anything it's really just It just lists all of the people
that are...
All the servers you have, and you just gotta find it.
So it's not very fun.
Alright, there's two Team A for some reason.
Alright, there we go.
Put that here.
Where do I want to put this here below me?
You just need to see my head.
I'll put it here.
All right.
Oh, the Lord icon.
I knew I forgot something.
It's all right.
Okay.
But if I leave, I'm not...
Okay, I won't be the last person.
I'll show you guys the Lord icon right here.
Wow.
Okay, that's a good Lord icon.
I will have to say.
I don't know about the glow on the eyes.
but that's a good lord icon.
I like that lord icon.
The default is this, but then she's like, meow!
That's all I can think of when I see her.
When I see her, I'm just like, meow!
Still not, still, okay, okay, it's just me and J3.
Not bad, yeah, not bad.
Not bad at all.
It's a pretty good one.
I actually like that.
that one yeah all right i'll join i'll unmute myself when
when we're all in the server i'll unmute myself because i am
scared of social interactions
okay when are we getting a wolf seem real just just say hi
that's that's you're asking for a lot right now
oh my gosh i'm so nervous it's been a while since i've
interacted with people i've been okay i need a lot wait no
that's not in japan i interact with people at irl but like i
have it's been a while yes i think you guys might notice i
haven't done any collabs in a while i i've just been so busy
you know like when you haven't talked to people in so long
that you just you're you just forgot how to I forgot how to
be a person.
It just, yeah.
So I was just like, how do you communicate with another
human being?
How do you, how do we, how do you speak to them and not be
awkward?
Oh yeah, new collab.
It's been, it's been hard.
It's been hard.
It starts.
It starts when it starts.
Yeah, my new year's resolution.
I will try to collab with a new person every other week, and
it has not started yet.
Look, when it starts, it starts, guys.
Just hasn't started.
Then, then, then we will start collabing with people.
Oh, my gosh.
But, yeah.
It's just, oh, yeah, apparently.
Okay, the other game.
The other game is, is, oh, Milky, thank you for the rain.
Thank you.
But the other game is weird.
It's like Black Cat versus Spider-Man, and it's hide and
seek.
But in Spider-Man, it's not allowed to climb on walls.
It's been that I've never played Spider-Man before.
So you're Spider-Man.
You're supposed to be hiding, but I've never played
Spider-Man before.
So it's like the last 30 minutes.
We're gonna play hide and seek with black cat versus
spider-man and I'm like all right We're gonna do it live.
We're gonna learn spider-man live You're just a man.
Yeah, you're not what do you do when you remove the core
point the core part of spider-man He is just a man.
What do you do with that?
What do you?
Put on manual swinging then I've never done anything i've
never even swung his fucking webs before
oh yeah okay so my sounding is like i'm only here for five
for 20 minutes so i should i'm mute so at least i'll i'll
like you listen to their conversation no yo i i swear i
might i might have clicked on the stream where you was just
trying shit i'm gonna lie i might have clicked on the stream
where you're just trying because i swear i don't know maybe
i was i'd be fraud sometimes i'll be playing i'm just like
joining in know this conversation i don't know any context
of what's going on no uh you just you just find it zero
context find it just go searching i got you oh my god
there's no other people i got you oh my god in human
interaction uh chat i did not hit eternity in season zero it
was actually season three i don't know how you got to say
that oh my god yo bro silky i love the duos we had lobbies
bro you went crazy I think I think it'd be impressive if I
went I got check I actually got check real quick listen bro
listen listen you got it it's fine no because I played like
I played with like certain people like I played like um I
played with vision like I played with uh like they're pro
players and stuff like that like i play with like a lot of
one of all people too and it's like the amount of finals
that these people rack up and then compared to me i just be
like wow like this is a big difference it's crazy yeah but
it's okay it's fun you i mean just you're almost dirty
they're just dirty that's what i wanted to say i'm actually
afraid of my management you wouldn't scoop so low i'm so
scared i'm so scared they're so sick lately give that up i
had to drop bro they kept nerfing him bro thing but you use
your look let me say something you come out with bp you get
two kills thing instantly comes out makes no sense i'm good
okay okay i don't got time for that i haven't seen i'm
usually the guy playing the thing you know if i see a bp i'm
instantly picking the thing that's wait so who's who's gonna
play black cat first okay bring silky down a bit bring tt k
i'm very intimidated he's she's fine she's fine It's fun.
I think it's likely broken.
So keep down.
Oh my god.
Where's my server?
I got so many options.
There's so many people here.
Oh my god.
I'm so overwhelmed.
It's like I haven't talked to people in 20 years.
Here's five new people.
Have fun, Doki.
I'm regressing as a human being right now.
Okay.
Ring TTK up.
Necrosis host.
There you go.
Hey pizza.
You think he goes spicy?
You think he goes body here?
Oh, no.
Oh, yeah, you could go spicy.
You said Dallas already.
Now we're going to have to spend 45 minutes fighting this
now.
Well, no.
I was just trying to go spider.
I'm not trying to get diffed.
I'm not going to lie.
I think there's only one way you go.
Server, no?
Oh, bro.
You could go spider, man.
I think on the PTR there is.
I believe in your spider, man.
Look at it, guys.
I talked.
Guys, I did it.
No one acknowledged me, but I said something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, 100%.
Everyone ignored me, but I said one thing.
Dot, dot, dot, after she said something, all right, anyway.
He just plays support.
He's a dirty, dirty trip.
It's a board abuser, I'm telling you.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, he does.
It's okay.
I'm proud of myself, Chad.
I'm proud of, myself the fuck said that yeah the worst they
could say is dude there's like who the fuck just said that
we had a six player we have a i might be one tricking luna
today he had oh wait any uh what do you mean i'll do a mix
opposed i'm not gonna flank i don't think i don't know i
don't know where's good where's your head go or do white fox
for the the team uh put the bag in the bag wait you have to
test out pennies are you wearing the black cat costume i
don't want oh i was but i took it off what do you mean what
i can't play with long sleeves wait wait wait armory let's
go on the flank do it our damage boost you oh my god no it's
the new map i've never played this map before wait where's
your tp you have to do it i've never played this map before
What?
Oh, I need to buy and stuff.
Give me a sec.
I actually never seen this map.
I just heard people say that.
I think I'm kind of cooked here, I'll be honest.
Okay, wait.
He got it.
I'm speed running, I'm speed running, I'm speed running.
I don't remember how to play.
Wait, watch Tima with Black Cat.
It just gives her another tail.
It slows and damages and heals.
Yeah, it does everything.
Wait, okay.
Yo!
Wait, he didn't even click the middle door.
Alright.
Wait, they're playing Elsa too?
Oh, why are we playing Elsa?
I've never played this map before.
I don't know where his way.
Wait, he's gonna...
He's tabling on you.
That's messed up.
Oh, man.
I've been doing this to Flats for like three previous...
I don't...
I've never played this map before.
I'm so confused.
I don't want to mess with a king.
necrows also wanted to run it doesn't run them no spidey
fade okay like he's scared how far spidey don't worry about
it oh i got no swings i got you i got you i got you oh i'm
running oh i'm running oh i'm grabbing oh they're angry with
me poker oh i'm jumping away please don't okay there's a new
black cat behind supposed to the old one oh my god i'm so
overwhelmed it's been too large okay in the back on captain
america okay wait what i thought you used it i'm with you
i'm with you i'm with you okay okay i was like you can grab
me midair he just grab me midair oh my god i'm not saving my
stats i'm not are they playing l some yeah there's a
I TP'd out.
You did?
That would be a lower weight.
Yeah, absolutely.
Ooh, can I get the snowflake?
I guess.
No, actually I want the snowflake.
I want the snowflake.
CDK, bro.
You play backline tank.
You don't need a snowflake.
Wait, what do you mean backline?
Oh, that's true.
You run backline DPS.
You do the same thing.
Wait, I don't have any divers.
You can play any divers.
Can win.
I'm out.
Oh, he's low.
He's low.
No, okay.
That doesn't count.
Walk up, walk up.
I'm on cap.
Puffer.
Puffer, Puffer.
Oh, I'm killing Puffer.
Cuffer is low.
Good Puffer.
Puffer fish down.
Okay.
I think it's Black Cat.
Where's the skin?
I really like Necro's skin like that.
That Black Cat's good.
I like his skin too.
where is oh that's the car ctk focus i'm focused i was like
where's the cart i didn't even know which one's the cart oh
the car is that that's that's the police wait what is that
ultimate well i don't know i'm ulting hello everybody i'm
scared i know how they call me there i'll be on this i'm
clapping why i got this oh i leave now i live i leave you i
got this he's dead I got her.
Where's she come from?
Blacks is coming in.
Coming to not.
I killed my wife.
But yeah, I was gonna say that.
Are you cheating on Fanta?
No.
You know, we all kind of fold hands together.
Guys, I'm gonna do it crazy.
I'm gonna do it crazy.
You guys do like...
Okay.
and you i'll let you figure it out stay there stay there
stay there how is everybody having so much fun and i'm just
struggling oh my god like you're on spider-man wait captain
is low captain's low all right we got one oh i can see all
the roll smiths this i like fox low this is awesome i'm in a
club corner i'm clapping wait support me there's an emma a
little puffer oh i like Cumber has a good name.
It does have a very good name.
I have a very good ult.
I actually hit five.
That's pretty nice.
You can 1B5 that.
Oh, I guess not.
I freeze her and I leave.
Boker, protect me.
I'm running.
Yep, shielding.
Yeah, you're the frontline Boker.
Yeah, we're saving you.
We're healing you.
Oh, I'm 90 on my own.
I can do that.
She has like nine abilities.
He's scared Yo, he just did some shit that maybe not If he
able to use the Red Slayer Oh yeah, he can ground you Go go
go He's another thing by the way So 3 I'm slashing Come on,
my ult's over Oh yeah, it doesn't have a cooldown They
shouldn't have enemies yet Yeah, they shouldn't have enemies
yet Can we just run triple supporter again?
I can run triple support I really like it Actually I want to
play ultraw on this game I caught dubs on ultraw No, I don't
want to play Ultron.
I don't want to play Ultron.
Whoever has the fastest PC.
Ranked games.
Ah!
He's on me!
I'm Elgin.
How you doing?
Fox is here.
I don't know what's happening.
I am being dragged away.
Loki saved me.
I did the best I can.
Oh my god!
I'm alive.
two seconds left okay silken, i'm spectating you lock in
it's okay it's okay we stopped at one minute oh he's
searching for me come in i can help you uh we have time we
have time wait what is this thing placed on me uh it's uh oh
okay i don't know anymore i we're dead well i think we're
dead slow ability oh that's the ground okay okay yeah it's
grounded and uh pulls you to the ground as well like a like
giga grounded all right tp oh look at kingpin is here i
never realized oh yeah so tall oh he's so bald what are we
getting that he's not wide enough though wait he's just like
you jay oh my god friendly fire what i have a lot of hair
did you not see my black cat cosplay that was pretty
beautiful is that them to ping oh no it's us that's us i
don't even know where he is oh he's above i might have done
okay there's no uh no old so we could we could go hard we
could go hard okay i'm going hard i'm clapping i'm going
really hard me too i used my ability for the first time uh i
forgot the hard i went in but i'm in i'm
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm leaving.
I got this.
I'm no longer there.
I'm watching.
I'm watching you.
Did he...
Oh, I don't think that worked.
Bugger just got five.
Wait, Flats is one.
Oh, Flats is one, yeah.
Oh, you're...
Well, I know I never...
I'm not.
I'm never doing...
Wait, I'm clapping for you?
I'm clapping.
I'm clapping, clapping.
Wait.
Can I not stun Necrows?
Oh, he can just cleanse it infinitely.
What?
No, this is outrageous.
I didn't realize he could just cleanse my own.
It's just like nothing?
Okay.
SK1, SK1 behind.
He's low.
Yes.
He's one.
Oh my gosh, we're drawbossing.
Oh my god.
What's happening in our backline?
Oh, the black cat.
She's just been jumping on her heads.
It works.
Oh, guys.
I have all here.
I'm resetting.
I'm all, I'm all.
Is my sports or dead?
I want to feed the wood charge.
I'm here.
That's huge.
That is huge.
Wait, come here.
Can you do this?
I can hold this.
Silky, you like the skin?
Are you ready?
They have, they have also.
You have to care getting also, Silky.
Oh, okay.
Let's.
I need a one side character, bro.
on the right on the right she used you can pop we can win
guys i popped it but i'm being dragged away it's okay it's
good it's good we can win we can win okay i'm one i'm one
i'm slashing i'm slashing not looking good guys i open
buggers about a six man oh wait did it hit six
that always beautiful
Thank you silk thank you wait what happened?
I hit like five people in cards.
Oh Shit, that was a big old.
That was a big old.
Thank you.
When it matters, I'm locked in I do not notice this map
confuses me so much
I thought you guys want who's playing ultra I got this I got
this I got it bring the TK down a bit Boga and Jade I got it
no you're not Getting my flag.
Bougar and J up the same amount.
Flang and I'm going to pop KDK and then you kill everybody.
Down a bit and then J3.
Wait, is thing cool bad now?
And Bougar up a little bit.
Oh, wait.
J3, you can join.
I keep forgetting you're fucking like, or Z.
I mean, also, I swear to God, I don't know how you can, I
don't know how to heal a Fuck you Spider-Man with white
flags.
I'm like, I'm sorry, you're dead.
You're gonna die.
You're gonna.
Oh.
Wait, oh.
They can, bro.
There's a, oh.
Wait, what?
Where did I go?
There was layers.
Wait, what just happened?
We didn't respect it.
There was layers.
What did I just miss out?
I was like, thank you.
Don't get into the portal.
When the portal disappeared!
Okay, it didn't matter, we still pushed it.
My death was just cosmetic, it's okay.
Guys, Ron is playing for me right now, so if I don't hit a
shot, this comes on Ron, okay?
Okay, okay.
Oh, shit!
Go to the left!
Okay, dude, okay.
Right here, right here, right here.
So when you hold it, when you hold it and you lock onto
them, it does way more damage, type shit.
Oh, yeah, yeah, like that.
i don't like this wait did angela get touched i don't i
don't think so i think he just wants to play angela
oh i'm i'm wrong wait they're so I want to push the fox.
Yeah, I'm going, I'm going, going.
We got bogey to be.
Oh, can we, can we?
Oh, I didn't know where you were.
That's one, that's one.
Oh, my God.
This E is so bad now.
Oh, yeah, you got, oh, it's so fast.
It's okay.
I need one to lock the fuck in by the way.
Can you tell him to lock in?
You're about to make my own man.
I'm out.
I'm clapping for you.
I need it.
Oh, no, you're good.
I shifted.
Where did you go?
All right.
Behind right now.
Okay, okay, okay.
They're trying to force my own backline.
trying to feel for you guys yeah yeah walk walk walk walk
walk walk oh my god you guys i got you guys i'm stomping the
grounds thank you i'm point guys i'm going back here keep
stomping stomping all right nice we're down here let's go
let's go nice or Ron, which one is it?
Watch eye, watch eye.
He's looking for it above point.
He's backing away now.
Oh, wait a minute.
Oh, what the fuck?
Hot guy, hot guy.
You're back.
Okay, okay.
Angela, Angela.
Angela is no.
Angela won, Angela won.
Clapping.
The flat is on it.
Shoot the black cat.
Okay, okay.
Black cat has black cat.
Nice.
Okay, go backline.
Go backline.
Gotta go on white box.
White box, gold net.
Oh, it's fine.
We got a point.
It doesn't matter.
Get away from that.
We got this.
That's all right.
They wasted the strangers.
Guys, there's a lot on me.
Oh, my.
Oh, poker.
I got it.
It was all.
It was in fact a seven man, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There was a seven player there as well.
It was crazy.
I got it.
I've had enough.
For some reason, I can see the white box.
Oh, I've had enough.
I think he got mad.
He started dying to me.
Oh, I don't want to die, bro.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Oh, why are you abusing things now?
Why are you abusing things?
I'm not abusing things.
I'm playing honorable character here.
Yeah, he was just doing two.
He was doing really well on Strange.
He had this nerf himself.
Yeah, yep, that's true.
Yeah, you should have seen that.
You should have seen that.
Oh, thank you, though, Kim.
Somebody saw it.
Yeah, I'm on living.
Why is it blue like that?
I don't know.
Okay.
She full house though.
Look, white fox, white fox.
I slowed the Angela.
Oh my goodness.
On you, on you, on you, on you, on you, on you.
Wait, is this what?
On me, on me, on me.
I'm gonna push the car.
Good shit.
Oh, Mari, okay.
All right, yo, yo.
All right, Mori, is Luna broken?
yes yes yes i heard like she's like almost has the same
damage as hella now right i think yeah that's crazy she
knows self-damage boost herself yeah so she can have more
damage than hella technically they had the angela oh we
don't have my luna i'll stop wait they're on guru wait what
the here is a white oh there was a black box on me wait can
you all oh god i'm Hey, break it.
Can we break it?
Oh I've survived so much worse.
Only 60 seconds left.
I think Deadpool's gutted.
We're good.
Don't worry.
They use everything and I have my life.
I don't think he's completely gutted.
It's just like...
What the fuck?
We just robbed us.
Where did you go?
All right.
I get all in.
Stop!
Stop.
Oh.
Me up.
can't he raised me up he raised me up goodbye goodbye
everybody goodbye everybody they have style here it's okay
well i'm gonna i'm gonna take it right above us that is a
loud helicopter oh my god ah how got you yeah yeah the
angela oh nice silky wait we have to touch a point bugger
you got that wait who's touching it who's touching it got it
i'm helping you i'm helping you i'm helping you i'm gonna
get siloed they're gonna oh no uh does someone use that cp
ability oh my god i knew he's gonna hold me i knew i'm 90 on
if we can stay on i'm pretty sure we could do this yes i
think so too oh my goodness oh my god she's actually nice
she's actually nice as hell oh my god wait uh puffer uh slow
puffer's low very low very low so is white fox oh she was so
one i'm dead i'm dead oh my god ttk you almost killed me
beautiful thank you thank you Gruto, no?
Or do they?
No, they should be close to it, but I don't think they have
it.
Oh, wait, I guess we could see.
He's 80.
Oh, I need to heal up here.
Got you.
We should go now.
We should go now earlier.
I have SIO'd again, guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Or whatever it is.
I can't really see.
I'm on the thing.
Huge, huge, huge.
Buffer low.
We have to push backline.
We have to push backline now.
Wait, I just got to...
on point i think you guys what does a black cat do oh nice i
don't know you can dash she can see you anywhere and then
she can dash to you anywhere as long as she's all behind us
so she's broken i did and then she does percentage damage
lock in oh okay i don't know she does percentage damage wait
that's crazy percentage damage yeah okay and whenever she
gets a kill her old reset wait wait wait if you get your old
can we can we try something i'm gonna push guy i want to go
like i want to try to teleport you from underground and you
like pop up.
Can you come to the lobby?
Yeah, I'm coming.
Wait, I have Angela on me.
Angela's on me.
Oh my god.
Doki Bird just got murdered.
I got all like, I couldn't do anything.
They know they know.
They here with their gun me.
Guys, they robbed Doki Bird.
It's okay.
Next fight.
Wait, can you look at that Angela on point?
Yeah, I just got stabbed.
Don't worry.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Yes.
One of these.
Oh my goodness.
So you just see that you.
Wait.
I'm going on a mission.
They saw your mission.
They did.
Oh yeah.
My bad.
That's what happened to me last time.
I'm gonna kill it.
I lied.
Oh nice.
Can you guys live?
That's a huge force if we can live.
I don't know if we can.
I can just live.
I'm hiding.
I'm getting like full rush done.
you got to touch a little bit yeah i have a you have to
touch he's about to kill everyone i believe in you i try i
try to touch oh my god no it's okay there's it's never your
bad or i'm wearing thanks poker i go on this these lobbies
are tough bro silky you are you did fine bro you got like
good you have 16 final kills bro and like the first point oh
it's okay i might stand back a little this is my third time
on white fox you guys are so encouraging and nice like i
love this man i don't get this with the friends that i play
with man you need better friends maybe we're on a neck you
know what i mean all right so i think it's i realize it's so
hard to live as white fox when everybody is on my ass like
also first time on the map dude i was like where is
everything guy that's tough i feel like i don't know i was
like i'm anti-dev but like i was like i can't anti this i
want to try ultra i felt like would you like a turn on luna
oh yeah i love to try someone can take a i'm gonna take a
i'm sipping we should go i'm gonna snow no all right so
squishy in darkness she is very squishy Oh, Gambit never
folds.
Oh, I didn't get to get a skink.
If I remember correctly, they didn't touch Gambit, huh?
Interesting.
I was just like, I was just like, I can grab, I was like,
goodbye, everybody.
It needs to be a single tank.
R.Mori plays tank.
Jay, I heard your bet that was pretty good.
Why?
RMori learns.
No, I'm joking.
All right, let me grab the cough trap real quick.
I'll do tank here.
I want to try the Bucky, though, man.
after and go i can i can go i'm all in there no no i'll take
this round get ready here should i try and pull the boker no
they're probably knowing they're waiting for it huh no no
they won't expect it they'll wait oh my god so what do you
guys can i ask that question real quick yeah so like like i
wanted i want to see the difference in chats right so like
my chat like if i'm doing like bad like they spam like gold
healing or so trash or so you know what i'm saying like does
your chat do the same like if you guys every chat does that
oh my god oh my god that's embarrassing twice in a row oh
that's crazy how did jay do that how did jay do it i don't
know man that's embarrassing wait they're on torch oh the
neck goes down oh my god um where are they far left i hear
behind me there isn't there's a black cat behind us okay i'm
gonna put a trap down for you dokey i feel like someone's
flinking i don't know i don't see many players yeah she's
still there she's like right here he's half here i'm giving
you a trap you can stand on my trap and she won't touch you
you see it
yes what wait torch is too fast oh i see it i see it yes
I'm getting punched in the mouth by clobbering times.
It's okay.
You're so healthy right now.
Wait, you're running hog and thing?
Okay, I froze hog.
Hook, hook, hook, hook, hook.
Ooh, there's a thing flying at me.
I'm going with those.
Okay.
I'm pushing.
Wait, thing is low.
Ah, I just got two tap.
Oh, big freeze.
It disintegrated that thing, though.
Oh, I'm one.
Oh, my God.
Folk is still the...
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
I'm...
Wait, J's ult?
How big is it?
Don't worry.
Necros DC in the back?
No, that's a crazy call out.
Oh, that's big.
Here's a frozen, too.
J is taking someone's damage.
Oh, a tank!
My fault, my fault.
I have all here.
But we could do damage first.
you're doing wonderful jay no i actually tank i'm not like
you bro oh okay oh okay let's go let's go necros look at
necros oh my oh we forced luna very good i'm backing up yeah
i'm backing they're gonna have torture right here wow i just
got hit by a hulk you're so healthy you're so healthy wait
clax wants me really bad guys trying i'll stay here i'll
stay here it's all right you have a permanent skill today
Torch in Torch in He's at you so fast Oh nice Oh Lady on me
Nice I might need a little Don't help me please Don't wait
She wants the 1v1 She wants an honorable 1v1 Cheating on fan
fan again Super no He is so fast I have to use it.
That's good.
Oh my god.
My god.
What is going on?
Goodbye, Leaf.
I don't even know what's happening right now.
Oh my god.
There's so many things.
There's so many things on my screen.
There's still a chance to stop them.
Oh my god.
Wait.
There's so many of us.
Could I have cleansed us out of that?
That I haven't?
Yeah.
Fuck.
No.
Nice shot.
Guys, I'm kind of popping off.
Not a huge.
It's good.
No the fog.
Are we jumping through this?
Get in there, Jay.
I'll heal you, Jay.
Don't worry.
Yeah, I'm here.
Oh, shit.
Your guys are actually in there.
Don't worry, Jay.
I'm in there with you.
I was in there.
I'm in there, still.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, this is frozen.
Oh, this guy.
Go this guy.
Oh, because, whoa.
Wait, I think there's a torch on me.
Oh, no.
Help Suki, help Suki.
We just got kidnapped.
Wait, don't help me.
Okay, don't help me.
Don't help me.
Wait, Jay, are you okay?
You're so, you're...
No, Jay, Jay's fine.
Uh, Black West is frozen?
All right.
It's Roamed!
Yeah, Jay, can you bully?
Jay!
It's okay, you're still alive!
You're still alive!
Oh, I can't swivel over again, bro.
I'm getting shoved in the locker!
You're still alive, you're still alive.
Oh, yeah, no, Luna is so broken.
The torch is so scary.
I'm going to hold soon.
You guys ready?
Yeah.
Wait, I'm kind of scared.
Oh.
I need help.
I'm trying.
She's low.
There's two flyers targeting me.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right.
I think this character is broken.
Oh What character Ultron?
Yeah Bye Wait, he got buffed?
Oh, what's his buff?
His oak got buffed Oh, is that it though?
He does like more range and more damage I think?
Oh, we have Yammila.
It like splashes a lot more.
Oh, Torch is one?
Yeah, he's solo.
Oh, goodbye.
Everyone's just getting kidnapped in front of me.
So scary.
You can't even do anything.
Ooh.
This.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Good kite, y'all.
Hey, SKS, give me a- Oh, I forced Luna.
I forced Luna.
No.
Come on.
Oh, my.
Oh, my expense.
All right.
Goodbye.
Let's push.
Look at the Luna.
Oh.
I fear you got own.
I fear you can.
And I have old again.
I blame TTK bro.
Wait, me?
Wait, what did I do?
Oh, what did he do?
He shot a freeze and got me stunned even on Ultron.
I just did nothing of the sort.
It's because Ultron blocked his view so he couldn't see the
freeze.
I'm sorry if I'm not common either.
It's like, I can't talk.
You're locked in.
Yeah, I'm locked in.
I love that.
Oh, um.
Oh, portal, portal.
I need help, help, help.
Really wants me.
Oh, I need help.
Oh, I got you.
I got you.
Oh, my God.
You deleted him.
Black out in the back.
Oh, no.
We're fine.
I'm trying to help you.
No.
I got juggled.
I didn't get the CC connection thing.
Oh, we have black.
No.
Oh, shit.
I saw that.
I didn't even see what happened.
Oh, my God.
same he like dashed to he dashed to the spider-man killed in
mid-air i killed like four there i reset my old like four
times yeah just watch out for the they're gonna do the spawn
thing again wait so i'm not really like a healer for real so
wait how much heal do you guys have i'm just trying to you
know like oh i got 13k 13 13 wait wait hold on you guys have
how much 13.
Silky, what do you have?
20.
You got 20?
Oh my god.
That's really good.
I can't wait to see that.
Especially since we've only had one tank this whole time.
Yeah.
It's really good.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Yeah, Silky, you're a natural bro.
You're a natural.
Almost sounds impossible.
You should be ranked one.
How much damage taken do you have?
32nd before you explode.
Get ready.
32,000?
Oh.
Oh damn, oh man, dude, that's how he got the heals from just
from G.
I've been here on the fly.
I've been hearing, you know, TTK, he's on that Ultron.
I'm saying, I've been healing him a lot.
He's taking a lot of damage, yeah.
He's really big, you know.
Really wide.
As wide as Kingpin.
Yeah, TTK was the model for it, actually.
Oh, what's that?
Yeah.
Oh wait, they're on Ultron.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
copy the swag i just can't believe it unbelievable who's on
otron yeah you guys think i can like put a portal behind
them and you push them into it you do whatever your heart
desires i believe in you whatever you decide to do i believe
okay say last you guys said you believe i mean i didn't say
we believe i'm not i heard you believe i'm trying i believe
so hard oh my god i'm missing this but i'm still believing
whatever your plan is uh jay's jay's almost there jay's
still they don't even know they don't even know wait there's
a black cat above us behind right now i got one who did i
get what happened wait you got one i don't even know who he
got oh emma was so low yeah i tried hello freeze
Here's somebody over here.
Guys, they stole our comp.
I got her.
Nice.
They're copying us.
It's all right.
I'm tired of telling.
We're better at this comp than them.
We have more experience.
We're gonna choke them back.
We're getting choked.
I don't need help.
I'm frozen, frozen, frozen.
Oh, I'm okay.
So you don't need help?
Yeah, no, I'm good.
Oh, yeah, we got him.
Oh, oh.
He's one.
Yeah.
I'll push cart.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Yeah.
Is it unfortunate or is it because of R and Mori's trap?
Uh, Jay, you're a feeder.
Oh, wait, I'm fucked.
I'm fucked, guys.
You guys have cooked.
I'm scared Jay help me Okay, Jay, I'm helping you.
Jay, we can combo our TPs lock in come here.
Do we have another TP?
Oh, I don't have a TP though.
Yeah, I'm gonna save.
I have a TP.
I'm the one with the TP lock in Okay, well, okay, I take it
to you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, anybody can see why you just tell me
no?
We're on a date.
Oh yo yo, I have my old.
I'm trusting you bro.
I'm trusting you.
I'm being touched.
You know, I'm just being really aggressive in the back line
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Luna's going crazy with those freezes, no.
I liked the attempt.
It was good.
We love this.
We baited their Luna freeze.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Push, push, push, push.
Let's cool down, let's cool down.
All right.
I almost have all guys.
You won't have our freeze, guys.
They won't have the freeze.
Okay.
Almost.
Oh, yeah.
He's got it.
Nice.
We'll play for our...
Our...
Almost have it.
Yeah.
Pushing.
There's an Emma behind us.
It's on our cabin.
Yeah.
Emma low.
Oh, my God.
I got you.
Good calm.
She really chased me like that.
Yeah.
Yeah, he was chasing you and you were just letting her chase
you.
I was like, so cute.
Are you okay?
Like...
A black hat will be one.
Oh my.
I got my own again.
Okay.
Beautiful team.
Yeah, I had no idea that was happening.
I didn't even know he was chasing me until he really started
hitting me from my heart.
Yo, I need out.
I'm with you, Jay.
I'm with you.
You are a goddamn liar, bro.
I have a drone on you.
It was not with you.
Uh oh.
We have gambit.
No, no, no, no.
We just wait.
I slowly back away Thanks so much We brought her over We can
gamble in when I'm back Alright, I'm ready Alright, I'm
ready to We're all here Okay, nice Oh, nice I just got
frozen up there Still die, maybe?
Oh my god, I'm getting, I'm getting grabbed I'm being
grabbed Clats is Clats is choking our team I'm burning the,
I'm burning him Phoenix I froze him I might need help though
I'm trying Oh my what is happening?
I'm looking for her.
I'm getting harassed.
I'm trying.
Yeah, wait, wait.
Where are you?
Oh, oh, this game has just been Doki Bird bodyguard.
I'm doing magic, bro.
I'm doing magic.
What is that?
Oh, I'm scared.
It's just it's just her.
He's just dashing to you.
He's on me.
He's clothes is on me.
She's so low.
All right.
Burn it, burn it.
He's so low.
All right.
here i'm on the cart wait wait i know one okay oh no it's
okay we have vulgar on my it's okay
i'm coming on vote i killed alona man i'm coming here i was
gonna say just go we could just go wait two seconds jay
waiting i'm waiting i'm waiting we ain't choked please don't
help me Don't worry, Elchon is healing you.
Wait, I'm getting...
Oh, wait!
Okay, never mind!
Jay's still getting choked.
Damn, I tried to keep you there.
That was a lot of damage.
This is our Emma.
I'm back, I'm coming back.
Who think we have an Emma?
I was like, we have an Emma?
She was just so close to me.
I just didn't think it was going to be the enemy.
Wait a second, a second.
We got a touch.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
Jay's got it.
I'm holding this down.
I'm playing the live, man.
I'm playing the live.
Wait, I need help behind.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm scared.
I'm also very scared.
Oh, I got combo.
I got...
Oh, no.
I'm scared.
Oh, my God.
He just chases me down.
Go down.
Two supports.
Keep touching.
Okay.
We have Gambit also.
We have Gambit.
Jay, I'm with you.
Just see alive!
I'm gonna keep spanking my bones!
Oh my god!
I'm close enough to hold it up!
You guys win that!
Help me!
Help me please!
My god!
I'm gonna get you!
I'm here guys.
I'm here!
I'm frozen!
We have capital!
Take me on my asses!
Yes!
You guys win that right?
He's a huge!
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming!
There's a low.
No!
Here.
Oh, my God.
TP!
Kill it, kill it!
Kill it!
I'm frozen by frozen!
Yeah.
Oh my god.
That is too easy.
It wasn't even hard.
I wasn't even slow.
Yo, you were guys healing at the end there?
It was insane.
Oh, my gosh.
That was crazy.
That was so suspenseful.
Oh, my goodness.
I was on Jethro Hogi, by the way.
Oh, my.
Well, I think there's a bug.
Wait, did they take my heal in a way?
Yeah, I was gonna say Stoki.
Yeah, you were just like you were 35k healing Yo, they took
my healing away Yeah, Stoki what the what happened?
Is this a bug bro?
Bro this like that has never happened to me bro.
Like that's like actually it's like so weird That's actually
so weird.
No, no, no, I'm gonna contact nettes.
I'm gonna talk to gong gong.
Yeah, no It's just we gotta get this checked out.
We gotta get this checked out something around the sets Yeah
What That's that's crazy.
No, Luna is so broken guys.
I mean, like she's literally a DPS.
She is she's a DPS that can somehow heal.
She's so fucking strong.
It's crazy how strong she is.
You'll need a top notch team to win this one.
Oh, no, no strategy make way for the king of teams.
We are cloak.
Life energy.
We are.
Elskog chain.
We nerfed cloak.
I don't know what else he did.
gotta test that one out it's 11 seconds now right they it
was less like they were in two seconds so whatever it was i
don't really remember oh let me do the cap team up who's
gonna be the black cat oh cap team up with black cat yeah
yeah do you want to play the black cat yo silky should be
the black cat i'm not gonna lie i genuinely I remember
hearing on Mori said that she wanted to play that.
What?
Yeah, I got that.
I just want to play the perfect human.
Look at this, guys.
Oh, my God.
Wait, these...
Feets for free.
Good grief.
I have two team-ups.
Log in.
I'm playing Spider-Man.
For free?
Oh, we need our healer.
Hold on.
It's okay.
I got this, guys.
He's the perfect being.
Yeah, Jay, you better do something on Bucky.
I want to see how much he got changed, man.
You can one tap with your ult, by the way.
One bullet in the head.
I have to go with Kielsen.
I'm done instantly.
Maybe Adam was not the pick.
Oh, wait, I forgot Penny got changed.
I did?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, is she like stronger?
Or was it, is a buff, right?
They're all one, I promise.
I promise I'm also one.
That's one.
Wait, are we ready to drop?
I'm gonna drop.
I bonded us and I'm flying now.
I don't know what my buttons do.
I need to swap.
No, no, I keep playing.
It's okay, Armory.
You cannot give up.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna all the healer.
You cannot be a quitter.
I'm giving up.
I'm trying to ult you.
I think I might be wrong.
Oh, you're crazy.
I saw haters.
Oh, Tron is.
It's very overwhelming.
There's like a thesis page.
You like that, right?
You like that?
I like that right there.
I like that.
That was brilliant.
Tiny shit.
But get plus, get plus.
Get him, Jay.
Get him, get him, get him.
Yeah.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
It's all right.
TTK now can play Wildcat or Black Cat.
Yo, yo, keep going, don't keep going.
I still got it.
Wildcats.
I've got my God.
Oh my God.
Oh, you're so good, Jay.
i'm coming back i'm trying i'm trying oh my goodness he's
going crazy we got you we got you i i can so buy this wait
there's an emma here i sold body myself oh what the fuck i
gotta know for you i gotta know for you nice sorry i have
res you can die on point get in there i just saw your kids
clash wait that's he's one oh wow do they have a a like uh
what's happening where are they spawned i need them to lock
in what did they change now listen i need a real match here
okay i'm trying to he needs the sr he needs the points i
need the points bro this is important he's the yellow oh we
don't have a black cat no why don't we have a black cat um
aramori no no no um waiter aramori abusing triple fourth
once again you never escape oh i hope i'll be jay just go
out there why are you more wait you're so scared you want me
to hit their spawn door i wouldn't help you don't be a yeah
don't be a yeah don't be a pussy jay yeah don't be a pussy
oh i'm flying away oh oh that's okay it's okay i slope on it
and now i'm flying away oh how about It's okay.
It's okay.
You are so dead.
Oh my god.
You're back.
Oh, he's got me just for you Wait, they're black hat
opening.
Oh, yeah.
I'm scared.
I don't know where they're black.
I can I don't know what that does It just dashes to you.
Yeah, it just does dashes.
He's what do you mean?
Hey, he's on everybody.
Who is he on?
on me.
What did she say?
I almost have a, almost, almost, almost.
I'm so scared.
I'm not there.
I'm not having any clicks.
Get in there, Jay.
I'm so fun.
I'm getting in there.
There you go.
Yo.
So Jay, you're supposed to kill the whole team.
Oh my god, bro.
I got you right now.
Give me two seconds.
If you keep me up.
Wait, he's low.
He's low.
All right, Mario, I got you.
You didn't keep me up, bro.
You didn't keep me up.
Wait, wait, what the?
There's an Elsa here?
Wait, wait, come here, sucky, come here.
No.
Wait, do we have a TP?
Oh, we're dead.
Sure.
Yeah, we do.
Yeah, we, yeah.
Well, now we're just respectful.
Do we have a DP?
I could see.
Yeah, I'm TP.
Oh, no, TP.
Oh, TP.
Hey, Jake, come back.
Do you see?
Say, you're not feeling this?
Like, no, no, no, no.
We went DP back to point.
Yeah, we're going to go hard here, though.
We're going to go hard here.
I'm just going to hit everyone.
All right, all right.
I'll still bond us.
There we go.
Let's go.
All right, let's not go.
I'm taking the TP.
Yo, I'm gonna make sure this is zero.
Guys, did everyone take it?
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
He's angry.
No.
You see what they did to us, bro?
He's angry.
I don't know why.
Why does he always turn us on sponsored streams?
He is always.
He's sponsored!
He doesn't care if I'm not sponsored!
Oh my god, it's my whole team.
Oh, oh.
Oh my god!
No!
I'm the only one to die out of that?
I cannot believe I didn't die.
Good yield.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Oh wait.
Do you see this?
Alright, here we go.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Do you see this?
What is that?
What's going on?
Wait, what the fuck?
I don't know.
I'm stuck.
How did that happen?
I'm sliding.
Can you like not jump?
Fix yourself.
Can you jump at all?
Wait, wait, what?
Can't do any movement abilities.
Oh, that's okay.
Okay, okay.
He's back.
Wait, do it again.
Do it again.
I am ready to put on a show.
I have Red is here.
Oh Oh my goodness.
Oh my goodness.
I was chill.
I'm just standing still.
No, no, no We have rise we have rise down point down point
down point down point I am pocketing Jade to the butterfly.
Okay
Oh, he's low.
Oh no, no Oh, that is not good.
Oh, I'm back.
Oh I hear someone behind or below me.
Oh, below, below, below.
Oh, he's stuck there.
He's low.
Oh.
Who are you beating up over here, bugger?
Yeah.
Who is that?
Oh.
Yeah, beat him up, beat him up, beat him up.
Someone that's gonna.
Yeah.
Get this guy, get this guy.
You got him?
I couldn't.
He scared me.
The current score is...
I think that was actually my only two finals.
I'm not gonna lie.
Next time don't jump in the portal without looking.
including which side this is uh this is why we have trust
issues yeah exactly bro now we have trust issues here
universe no matter the cost
there's no us without trust bro now you just broke that what
are supports do they change really uh cloak got nerfed adam
got buffed luna got buffed wait adam got buffed again wait
what did he get buffed his healing uh so whenever you land
your right place it used to reduce the cooldown of your
healing and now it does more like it reduces more whenever
you land them wow that's so tough wait they nerfed tank pool
too yeah yeah i know that was so bad no you're not like so
bad but it's definitely a difference wait wait wait wait so
what what do i like what do i buy first because i i went i
went just you buy your top right no wait did it who else who
did they buff guys i won't play my jp my turn on ultron i'm
gonna trust you and i'm gonna take you i'm gonna take it i'm
taking it i'm taking it you wouldn't kill so yeah i i we're
good friends yeah yeah i wouldn't kill you i'm gonna i was
like now but i'm not tping us okay so there's no yeah i'm
still taking it bro yeah no tp bro yeah i'm tp what if you
just tp all under the ground and we just die okay you guys
are just all waiting all right there's a baby over here has
there always been a baby all right all right yes it's uh
it's iron fist uh chungus i think okay you ready guys i'm
ready yeah okay i'm ready i'm waiting get his ass get him
get him get him get him get him get him is it happening jump
oh it is jump on we're doing like negative
I'm out One that goes to the spot kept SK That bug is dead
Where did everybody go?
Oh my god I'm in this one wait, stay back here with me.
I got SK down SK down Whoa Oh,
I'm coming with you Oh, are we all going to spawn?
It's okay, I'll be on main.
I'll bait them.
Wait, she knows.
She knows.
She's a lion.
Let's want to come out.
Woo!
Wait, wait.
Wait, are you guys all driving the all time?
It's the Wolverine now.
I can literally- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa.
Oh, no.
Go point, go point.
Yeah, let's go back.
I'm not gonna think we left and then I'm the only way back
I'm I'm going back no I'm staying I'm going back at one
point I got this oh my god I'll wait here she was fighting
I'm gonna wait here until my teammates are back I'm here
teammates here right here I'm here I's your back I'm
actually back oh what the fuck Do I think I can make it to
spot?
Oh, I got you, Jay.
Oh, I can.
Huge, huge, huge.
I stunned them.
Don't worry about it.
Lock in.
I got you, Jay.
I got you.
You're huge.
Good heals.
I got you, Voger.
Well, I don't know if I can heal through it.
I don't think I can heal through it, but I still got you.
Nice.
Heels are boring.
That's crazy.
Yippee.
Okay, I'm trying to steal this guy.
Oh, they TP'd.
They linked.
I'm scared.
Nice.
My god.
Black apple right there.
A nice deep freeze.
Bro, we don't have a black cat.
Oh yeah, I just realized.
You're right.
Black cat's going crazy.
No, that was great.
You put her in a cage.
I put her in a cage.
There's an atom behind us.
Nice.
You can head tap with Penny.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I didn't even know that.
Now I'm my oldest hunter.
Suki, you see how he doesn't want to mirror your spidey?
Oh, they're running triple support now.
He's scared, he's scared.
I'm actually scared.
I'm about to die.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Jay, cover me.
Got you?
Covering you?
Where are you?
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
I better not see this team gameplay in a hundred Ds this
week.
Oh, I am saving my stats.
Oh
All right, no Just poke this spider-man in particular Wait,
he ran away Surely she comes out of spawn, right?
Oh my god No, oh, oh, oh, they use these all these all all
all right.
That's fine.
I'm not mad at that All right, maybe do us a point where the
merge cut was not in I feel really mean.
I'm leaving.
Cosmic rays didn't make me who I am today.
My family did.
Oh my god!
They look like they mean business.
Oh.
I like that double pullback.
I'm popping behind.
Oh, you got this, Jay.
You're so healthy.
Oh yeah, Jay.
Go crazy there, Jay.
Oh, can you get it?
Three.
Two.
I'm going in, I'm going in, I'm going in.
I tried to take him off the map.
You still have that?
I actually tried to take him off the map.
No, now I don't.
Now he's gone.
I'm just slowly pushing.
Doing my job.
Oh my goodness!
I got knickers.
There's a black catcher.
coming over the thing oh nice up oh i was dead
holy what the fuck solo to necros solo to necros they're
evil i'm coming are you guys okay over there because i'm
just gonna push cart nice all right yay three car push no
that felt evil no that felt wrong why did armory come to the
third spawn and just help me just do a murder
look at that guys i just stayed on the payload i did my job
i did some i did some crazy i did my job guys just like i i
didn't deserve to live that but what did you do i i placed
the tp in their backline and i just kept going in and out in
and out in and out and then they started chasing me and then
i did that and then that uh ability i did that and then i
went invisible and then they couldn't find me oh does it not
like what is there not cool down for like the portal no
there's no cool down for your items you can just keep
spamming oh no but like for the portal does it go away after
oh it does it does go away but you can place a new portal
right away oh and then you keep going that's crazy of money
i mean you get you get 300 coins every time you land an e
and then your dash gives you 50 per hit and then the portal
is 200 so it's super easy to keep getting money oh there's
like crazy combos you can do it is beautiful man it is
beautiful silky you should play her okay you know what now
i'm locked in and i'm playing bp let's do it oh okay i'm
playing i her black tie is like the upgraded vp though yeah
she is you go all so her all is just she just dashes her all
is her resets when you hold after resets right so her oath
when you press it it just tags everybody on the map every
enemy and if you have line of sight of them i'm like it
doesn't matter how far away they are i think the range is
like 100 meters so it doesn't matter you can just just dash
to the enemy supports and if you land the kill uh it resets
the cooldown so you can dash again to anyone and then you
keep can keep chaining that damn that's actually melee
players rise up it's your time to shine i've heard enough we
got a burp we got a we got a nerf bv i think i've heard
enough to the ground
i hate like out of definitely out of all the support
characters luna most busted and fun out of all of it debut
it's actually crazy how how busted luna is i actually i just
like oh yeah oh it's hide and seek time well technically you
can still play black cat if we're the seekers wait i'm
excited for this wait who's who's who's gonna yeah it's like
spider versus Black Cat, but you can't climb walls on
Spider-Man.
it's like, whoever's Black Cat has to get 30 kills within 10
minutes.
What?
Oh, okay.
I'm understanding now.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, they changed the rules.
Now you can use wall climbing.
Never mind.
You can climb as walls on Spider-Man.
Guys, Before then, it was like in red text, like, can't use
wall climbing.
And then they, I guess, I guess they're like, maybe, maybe
we shouldn't restrict Spider-Man movement.
And now it's like, can use wall.
It's like in bright red text, can use wall climbing.
So now we can.
I swear it was in red text, can't use wall climbing.
So it was changed.
I'm pretty sure it was changed.
They just crossed out the T.
I was like, wait a minute.
I swear.
I saw that.
They were like, don't use wall climbing.
I swear to God.
I saw it.
He must have played bot games like last night or something.
Oh, oh, what oh 18 to 18.
Oh God Grand Garden
Why are we why why are we waiting on like is the setup that
long?
Oh,
yeah, it's gonna be so hard to find the spider-man Wait, are
we the spider-man or are we the black cat?
That's a good question.
I'm just a guy.
Just a dude, bro.
Dude, this map is so big, too.
It's just going to be, like, air, like, what's it called?
It's going to be, like, space wars.
All the Spider-Man's just doing rollouts.
Like, I'm just thinking, like, how the fuck are we going to
catch up?
We're going to have to wait till we get all and then press
Q.
I mean Well we can't decide Necros is the The lobby leader
So I have no choice in this matter I don't have rights here
Oh Wait Necros is Oh what Where are they going?
No they joined our team They're all Wait are we Why are we
joining teams?
Maybe we're getting all teams together For this Oh We're
fighting We're fighting we're fighting 12 bots 18 bots
there's just is it i mean we have like less than i think
it's just i know i genuinely don't know what's happening i
think we're playing uh hide and seek but i know how that's
gonna happen yeah oh yeah no the other team the other teams
are joining now oh cool oh wire all right 12v12 okay that's
better because i was gonna say garden is such a huge map but
like it's gonna be so hard to find people
okay so the spider-man team is the hiding team i would
assume so wait saws was another take up like thing oh you
can bro go for it just for somju just for somju wait all
black cats versus all black cats down.
I mean, all right.
Yeah.
Yeah, fuck Spider-Man.
For who?
The hell?
That's right.
Wait, we're not doing the hide and seek?
How to do free fight.
I wasn't supposed to be a free fight, though.
It's like...
Okay, cool.
What if you all join the same call, yeah?
That would be so funny.
That's gonna be like the fastest Muta every for me i think
it's just gonna be like noise like yeah what are we doing
what are we picking it's all black cats versus black cats oh
god get locked in meow
but she changed her pose pretty accurate all right thank you
i do i do want to become a voice
I can't change but I can't change my character
Eight black cats and one thing.
Oh, you can't.
Oh my god, what's going on?
Yo, what's up?
I'm good.
Oh, I don't care.
Oh wow Guess I'm not so unlucky after all Yo, yo, yo,
where's the heals, guys?
I need someone to jump.
Yeah, who's healing?
Heal me, heal me, heal me, heal me.
This is my tongue though.
Oh my god.
Okay, what do I buy?
There's so many things to buy.
A lot of things to buy.
I don't even know what I just bought.
I mean, click and stuff.
Do-do-do-do.
Donkey, come here.
I'm dead.
Where you at?
I got that portal.
There's a portal?
Oh, there is a portal.
Oh Oh Oh, oh my god Oh my god, I just killed everybody Oh
Oh, goodbye Can you grab that?
Oh my god, there's so many black cats here Oh Sorry, I'm
looking at my shop No way No What won't bring in this?
I don't think he was that outrageous I can't die to a no
damage rocket I can't bro good fortune what do I get up from
here oh shit oh my what did I do noink you won't be needing
this I I won't be needing that Where's the heels?
Where's the heels team?
Yeah, I need heels.
Yoink up some heels Everyone's just yoink in my pockets
Yoink I can't make money because everybody is taking my
money.
Yeah I'm gonna gamba fuck this.
Oh, oh, oh, oh Yoink I need money to gamba
I'm just oh my god don't gamba it was not worth it It was
not worth it.
Gambai is not worth it.
It's not worth it.
Wait, but I saw in the trailer they got a thousand.
I lost it all.
Never give up.
Never back down.
90% of gamblers quit just before they hit a big.
That's so true.
I should keep gambling.
What's happening?
What is happening?
Oh my god.
Who's passed?
Did we cross?
Oh my god.
She actually chased me down.
I think we just gotta use all our ulti.
at the same time i actually canceled it oh my god i'm just
again gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha to try and tell you to
gamba keep gambling keep gambling oh wait i'm gonna gamble
right now oh my god i made money i made money i'm gonna
gamble again i lost it all i lost it all wait i just gambled
i lost the house yeah i lost it all i had a hundred dollars
happening There's a lot of people there.
I don't want to go into that.
Okay, I'm just...
I don't even know I could double jump on this character.
I gamble.
Yeah, you can.
Rez.
Yoink.
No way.
Oh, I'm dead.
Yoink.
Wait, don't gamble.
I just lost everything.
No, it means you have to gamble again and then you'll get it
all back.
Trust.
okay i'm doing it misfortune i lost it all that means if you
do it again you'll get it all
by the way you don't have to open this shop to buy stuff you
just press the numbers i just i realized wait you can press
oh my god one two three four five six yeah you can just
press the buttons without opening the shop i want another
old oh yay oh my god did you are just so much better yay wow
big win i was just kill stealing to be honest i wasn't doing
anything i was just gambling oh my god yo jay i just
realized jay what's up oh my god no i realized who i mixed
you up with i'm gonna buy bro i'm gonna say it bro wait guys
wait you i'm so good at stealing money oh my god i actually
wait like how do you know you know what i'm gonna be doing
so like late night right i just i'll roll up i get hot and
then i just start cooking on my rivals i'm like i'm a
natural let me see what i can you know grab some information
from what role i want to play before i go throw people's
games on my altar yeah who would have thought no but i don't
really throw games i just try to i don't even know what i
was doing i was just gambling they are so different like is
EU, J is NA, and one of them is both.
I won't say wish.
Dude, that's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
Wait, wait, no way.
Okay, what is Gab number one?
One and six.
Okay, one and six.
I just got to remember one and six.
No, bro.
That's crazy.
Noy.
Okay, that's crazy.
That's crazy.
Oh my.
No, I wasn't.
No, I didn't.
You mom told me I would never laugh at you, bro.
I understand.
I understand when we just said, I'm not going to lie to you.
i would never laugh at you bro i'm no i started laughing
because i like bro like bro your chat says i'm so funny like
the way you go 94
you're fake bro i i understand where we're out now now yoink
yoink yoink yoink yoink yo
it's no yeah he knows the combo he'll just kill like 10.
i'm going gamba
no oh they're coming they're coming oh no oh no he's easy oh
my he's one he's one
no he's just one yoink no no please don't kill me oh my god
don't kill me can there be a healing ability is i know right
gabba can't ever trust your supports i'm gonna cap this
health pack oh my god there's so many over here i know right
oh my god we're eating them no wait we just eat them it was
20 of them
Yoink!
Oh my god, I'm being...
Oh my god.
I'm being jumped.
Okay, I think they figured out the combo, guys.
I almost have a winnable.
You're in the lead now.
Try to make it left.
They've come from behind.
But you can still turn this around.
Give me that luck.
Oh.
Where is everybody?
Oh, they're all like here.
Why would I do with this thing?
Oh god.
Oh.
What is this personal?
Oh my god.
You're doing so much.
No, no, I don't want to be down here.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh my goodness.
Just don't gamble, bro.
Just don't gamble, guys.
Don't waste it, bro.
Trust me.
I'm gambling.
I'm leaving I'm so low I did next though no I didn't please
let me kill him no so close Gamba I got $400 $500 Gamba's
worth it Gamba's worth it this is no way
They're all one, they're all one.
Oh, yeah, they were.
You didn't lie.
Oh, shit.
There's three people here.
Still got a few lives left.
Hey, guys, the game's pretty close.
Got a lock in.
I'm definitely not locked in.
I'm going to...
I think we got to be in a cat pack.
Oh my goodness wait wait.
Oh wait.
It goes past a hundred wait.
We need one more 120 120 120 120.
Yeah We got group up.
That's how you win
Coming up coming up coming up why is he so slippery.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
I'm so confused I'm not a lot.
Is this I don't know what's going on like I just hear,
gotcha.
Gotcha.
The only end of my bot is gambling.
Oh yeah, who's gonna get a final kill?
Who's gonna get the final kill?
Oh, where am I?
Yay!
Oh my gosh, Flats, that was so clutch.
Flats are so beautiful in Dalvin.
Guys, from the top to the...
I've already fell off.
it only took one game i was so down bro if you i need a
boost bro okay hit me up we i'm gonna i'm gonna add on real
real i'm gonna add all right all right bro so bro thanks man
you're all
Bye-bye.
I was like, I was too confident.
It's okay.
She's time to find someone new.
I flew too close to the sun.
You know what?
I'm down to play some, you know, the night's still young.
I'm down to play a couple of rankings.
That was fun.
I slowly remembered how to interact with you.
human beings slowly remembered how to how to talk to people
i i'm trying to reintegrate into society right there and i
oh my god i'm i'm getting it i'm i'm figuring it out again
i'm sorry i'm recalling social cues exactly all right let's
go play some rink games guys thank you again to my rivals
for the sponsor today if you guys want to check out the game
please feel free the click on the link pinned in the chat or
on the paddles below and you and it's free to play remember
it's a free to play game guys uh that was pretty fun i
definitely i don't know just playing melee characters is
just like a road bump for me that's just like oh yeah by the
way uh tomorrow i was gonna tweet about it i made a youtube
post about it but the announcement got postponed to next
week so um announcement is gonna be next week now on a
tuesday maybe maybe on a Tuesday so um so I was told it got
postponed so tomorrow I might play the typing game the
battle royale typing game yeah we're gonna reclaim Tuesday
after this Tuesday I'll reclaim Tuesday all right let me
what's this
Alright, let me...
What do I want to do?
I wanted to change...
No, I didn't want to change any settings.
Alright, let me...
Change my Twitch style.
Yes, that's what I wanted to do.
Oh, shit.
Wait, there was something else I want.
Uh...
Back to Elo terrorizing.
I need to plug in my Super Strike mouse.
I got that.
got the mouse like two weeks ago i think and i still haven't
plugged it in i still it's still in the box outside my door
and it's just sitting there i just didn't have time i don't
have time i'm sorry i just don't have time like video games
these days because i've been so busy behind the scenes with
this fucking thing that's gonna be announced finally next
week and then everything will make sense Everything,
everything it will make sense when it's announced.
It will all make sense.
I barely have time to play video games.
That's why I was like, what am I doing on white fox?
I was like, I close my door.
The sponsor's over.
There's, there's, the sponsor's over.
The sponsor is over.
The sponsor, you're no, there's no reason to park.
Give me a second.
I'm gonna, okay.
He's just barking the bar.
He's not hungry or anything.
I fed him literally like a couple of hours ago He's just
making sure There are always a good He had his walkies.
He had his fucking walkies and everything There was Alright
It has been a while.
Let's finish my last placement game.
Let's see how it goes My final placement game, but that was
fun.
That was a fun, um, that was a fun sponsor.
I did not know what I was doing.
I felt like, I know I was playing White Fox not correctly
because I was just mashing buttons when I got too pressured
because I was just like, what do I do?
I have no more cooldowns.
What do I do when I get dope by two people?
Like, by three people.
Like, I don't have my TP.
I don't have, like, my right click.
I, what do I do?
I was like I don't know just all the buttons Just something
would work right Surely something will work Oh yeah the joy
What was it that the Deadpool now has His own twerk email
Which I obviously I had to But it's not the same as Venom
though I will have to say Oh wait it's boxes you show Yes he
has his own maid cafe
Let's see Cosmetic Where is the emote?
There it is.
I mean...
Whoa!
Actually, wait.
I'm ready to...
Okay, let's equip this too.
Alright, I'm ready.
Whoa!
The little spink for the extra.
That's...
Oh!
Oh my god, let's go
We know this guy
He has to compete with Venom somehow That is true He's got
to add a little bit more oomph to it You know?
He has some competition right now Wowie Deadpool Go get him
Oh Which hero do you think you want to be today?
It has been a while.
I'm back, baby.
What if I play White Fox?
I don't even know.
Oh, yeah, Cloak.
Cloak is still meta.
She's still meta.
I don't have fame.
Listen, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Oh, True Nova.
Thank you for gifting us up.
Thank you.
I'm sorry I missed your thing.
It's been a while since I streamed.
on Twitch.
It's hard to, like, sometimes I forget how to go back and
forth.
Cloak and dagger gel for now.
Also, because I don't have...
Luna was so fun, though.
She's actually more fun.
I think she's more fun than, like, early season, Luna.
Just covers her damage.
Her damage is crazy.
It's actually insane.
Yeah, she's back, baby.
Like, when I was on Luna.
I felt like I was actually, I actually left an impact on the
team.
Like, I felt like I was actually contributing.
Oh, shit.
Okay, no, okay, Gambit is not.
All right, yeah, Cloak and Dagger didn't get bad.
Let's go.
Let's snuck and go.
It's time.
Oh, we don't have DPS players.
Oh, Oh my lord, bro.
How many lords do you have?
Never mind.
We have a very flexible player.
We just have the ultimate, as much as the average
unemployed.
Let's go.
We have an unemployed player.
Surely that means he's good at the game, right?
I mean...
Oh wait, the Hulk has...
Champion.
Okay, I was gonna say it.
They're not champion animated.
Having a job is overrated.
Yeah, but how would you afford the lovely skins?
The beautiful skins in Marvel Rivals.
Hashtag not sponsored right now.
Not sponsored.
Okay, I'm not in business.
I was trying to...
Not now.
The port are in this?
What did he...
Oh, he's so...
Oh my god, you're so healthy!
Oh my god, that was so...
Thank god!
Oh my god!
That was the unluckiest time that I...
had to reload.
Thank God.
Thank God I had an thank God she had Invis.
I was like oh no.
What a shame.
What a shame that I had to reload there.
I'm backing up.
Goodbye everybody.
You're so healthy.
You are still so healthy.
See everybody is so healthy right now I told you I would
never lie well not him though not him
it's okay it's okay we are I'm backing up just in case just
in case the whole Oh
Wait champion okay, I'm surprised I got I mean actually I'm
not surprised I'm not surprised I got out first.
I literally peeled like my life depended on it Not on me my
all was great My all was great was not my fault Oh Oh I made
an impact.
I did my job.
All right, let's go.
It's so easy when you don't have to aim.
I even try when I could just do this.
I could just look at any direction I want.
What is going on?
Oh, shit.
You're so healthy.
Oh, my god.
Alright, look at that.
I saved.
Oh, he is so dead.
He is so...
Oh, my... Oh, he was so gross.
It was so gross.
I'm surprised he didn't ult that sooner to save.
Oh, they double support ulted.
Let's go.
That's what I like to see.
Don't...
Don't!
Never mind.
Yeah.
I didn't...
I didn't count properly.
I forgot when the up end.
I was just like, I'm so safe.
Surely the up won't end in the middle of all that.
Oh.
That's not on me.
I just got here.
I just made it.
You cannot blame me on that.
I literally just came back from spawn, yes.
There you go.
Don't worry.
You can live through this.
Oh.
Well, not him, though.
I'm backing out.
Goodbye.
I don't believe it.
I don't know.
I have trust issues right now.
I don't believe right now.
It's really hard to believe.
Especially in Grandmaster.
It has...
Oh, he definitely has.
Unless...
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man!
Oh, no!
No, I have to reload!
Oh, we all do!
You're not special You're not fed up.
Why would you leave me?
Fed up just slowly walked away Why did he slowly walk away
from me?
Oh, bye guys Oh, please tell me I make it please tell me I
make it though I hope you like which one.
We have two Venoms.
Oh, Felicity.
Oh, I think I know which Venom it is.
I think I know which Venom it is.
I was like, we've talked about.
There's two of them.
Good boy.
I'm in the trenches.
This is the life I have not be playing it regularly.
This is the life I haven't played.
Too much in a long time.
I've been stuck in the...
God.
Do you think he'll be okay?
He will.
Do you think?
Don't.
Don't worry, Sue.
I got...
you oh my god he lives let's fucking go oh my god i have to
use this you know what let's see if i live let's go let's
fucking go i don't i'm i'm making no impact doing this but
let's go
oh my god oh my god i'm sorry i'm so sorry I was on- I'm so
sorry.
I was on Lil Corp.
I was too confident.
It's okay.
Her death was just a cosmetic.
It doesn't mean anything.
Where the fuck?
Okay.
We heal each other.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I don't know what to do here.
You're gone.
I...
There was no saving us.
We might actually triple support.
Oh!
She's dead!
Oh my god!
That was so good!
Have you tried not to die?
I don't think we could have.
I don't think we could have survived that.
I...
You know, I...
You know, I'm just switching things up.
at least it's not my fault at least you know you know in the
end i wasn't the one to blame in the end do we have like
three oh my god i don't think we have dps oh no venom is our
dps but he's like the ultimate flex support or not flex
player because he's unemployed that's what that guys you
feel he said that not me I'm just repeating what he said I'm
just repeating what my fellow Magneto said toky it's just a
quote the only thing you're smashing is my elo yeah our team
I just realized our team has died, but they cannot fucking
die.
They are out diving like us My my infants and I are not
living right now.
We are not okay
All right That's right no pause today spider-man that's
fucking right
No pause today All right, I'm just gonna chill here here.
Okay, bye.
Our soul.
That's not our fault.
Where am I?
I'm still alive.
I got lifted in the air.
I got lifted into the air.
Everything was happening at once.
Alright.
Oh, that's alright.
Don't worry, I got you.
He's still up there, guys.
What are we going to do about that?
Are we just going to let him walk away?
We're just going to let him walk away?
All right, that's cool.
I guess we're just going to...
Oh, God.
You're still alive.
It's all right.
Everything is okay.
Nothing to worry about.
I blinded him.
He can't see now.
all right just in case i see you spider-man i see you don't
make me dox you peter parker oh my god oh my god
all right that's fine you know what let's do it let's do it
let's go oh we made them i i don't know what That's all it
was from our siloed, but I'll throw it.
Oh, shit.
So I got you.
I got you.
Don't worry.
Whoa.
That's illegal.
I don't know what siloed was trying to out there.
I don't know why he came into the room with me.
Doki the doxer?
Okay.
It's okay.
You could just wipe their memories again
I'm like debate fuck it.
I'm gonna use it because I want to blind him That's right.
I'll blind you forever I don't I don't think this is when I
just from I Don't know my team is just Oh, but missed let's
go.
I missed Oh wait, we have the thing!
So like...
There you go.
He is blinded now.
No, we could have committed it on this guy.
I don't know why we left.
Oh, never mind.
We did not commit.
That's alright.
It's okay.
We didn't want to come in.
That's okay.
Yeah, well it's soon again.
And then I'll use it aggressively.
Fuck it.
I feel like I should just use it all aggressively because we
don't really have anything for it.
Oh!
I'm so good!
My team's dying.
My team is dying.
Alright.
My team is dead, but it's okay.
It's okay.
There we go.
every you know I that's not my fault that they're dead how
is I supposed to know that would happen I don't even know
they used anything to counter it holy shit thing you are so
aggressive for no reason all right we got the cloak out and
then that's unfortunate I don't want to be in there that's
also unfortunate but we did nothing with that that's alright
I'll blind her now she can move up everything is fine I'll
just keep healing everything is fine holy shit I'll just
keep healing everything is still fine technically alright
watch this
I might have held that a little watch see so that's what
you're not supposed to do see that guys now the next time he
does it let me show you how you're supposed to close the uh
phoenix up guys so what i showed you was what not to do so i
hope you all watch that and realize like why it was like a
bad thing to like the timing is very important and i hope
that was a lesson to all of you guys on how to time your
cloak up correctly.
I need to always, I need to not, I need to remember to stay
on cloak for him whenever I'm here.
There we go.
Oh shit.
Now when he does it again, Armed and dangerous!
That is.
Oh, use it to run away.
Let's go.
Maybe I should have healed.
Alright, yeah, see, take notes, take notes.
Get ready.
When the Phoenix does it again, I'll show you how to
actually do it.
Now we have a Spider-Man?
Alright.
I'm 50% backed up.
I don't think he...
I don't think he gave webs to anybody.
Holy shit, okay.
You guys see that?
I cloaked it.
Yes.
You guys see that?
It worked.
It worked, yes.
Oh, that is not.
good for me that is not good for me oh my god he was so
close to getting healed can you do it again i think our
other dps is is playing he's playing uh he's playing like mr
heels he does not know what to play he plays all the melee
characters but not very well
I feel like he is, I just don't think it's working.
Oh, I didn't cloak.
You just told me to hop on thing.
Oh, that was a huge lie.
Nope, I have no idea where it is.
Raid!
We had a good stream!
Hello, I am...
I'm fighting my demons right now.
Lawn!
We have a good stream.
Thank you for the raid, guys.
Thank you.
I'm just fighting my inner demons right now in rank.
Just the usual.
You know?
Why do we...
Why do we do that?
No, no.
I can't.
Unfortunately, or fortunately, this is one of those days
where I can't...
Despite how much I would love to...
I can't...
Oh.
Ooh.
Oh, whoa.
Where's my other support?
Ooh.
I would need you to push up because I...
I don't know why our invis was so scared running away I
don't even know who to avoid I don't even know support I
don't think this is a support diff do you not see the crayon
eaters I have on my the support Canyon.
Um, who said that?
Mr. 46k 46k healing with just 1,000 damage more than me?
Um.
Um, I will say their Invis might have been better than my
Invis.
My Invis was a little confused.
Okay.
Alright, I'll avoid...
And then...
Okay, this guy was playing...
At least this team will never get close to me again.
I will never come close to my presence.
Yeah, oh yeah, my inverse was definitely invisible.
It's okay.
Have something that can cheer me up as always.
Bop, bop, bada, wait, he should be like, yeah.
Wait, here we go.
Yeah.
That's right.
Smack that dead fool.
Yeah, that's the best part.
You can avoid people.
Bop, bop.
Oh, yeah, there's made Jeff now.
Unfortunately, he can't work.
Or fortunately, if that's...
Whatever floats your boat.
Where is he?
There you go.
There's also Meg Jeff.
I don't think he has...
Do I have this equipped yet?
I do.
Yeah, he doesn't have any...
Wait, where's the...
Did I not buy it?
I thought I bought...
Okay, here.
Oh yeah, so you can also ride him too.
But only in like practice range.
Wait, no, I don't want to gift it to anyone.
What the fuck?
This is my money.
Let's add that in here.
Yes, you can... Anyone can, like, ride on Jeff now, too.
You can be a little... A little pony.
A little pony.
Of course.
Wait.
Wait, Jeff has a twerking?
Wait, he does?
Why is there a diamond player in here?
What the...
Wait, that- Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
How- Wait a minute.
Wait.
Wait a- Wait a minute.
How do I- How is the year?
How the fuck is the year?
I mean, tank pool is still strong, right?
We're still in the tank.
We're still in the tank pool.
Yeah, we're still in the tank pool area.
I'm just like, how did he- get here excuse me sir you're in
the wrong lobby and also why are you on my team why i
thought i had streamer privilege where is this privilege
excuse me sir i believe my privilege isn't here
all right
Why Invis?
Oh, Black Panther.
We have a Black Panther player.
That makes sense.
All right, Cloak and Dagger to actually with Ultron.
Wouldn't it be better for Mantis?
Because then it'll be like one main healer and then two Two
other healers where we just want to run around and have fun
And then I get to fuck around
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, where did it?
Wait, was she- did she always not have eyebrows?
People often mistake empathy for weakness.
Yeah.
I was gonna say, I'm pretty sure she had eyebrows.
Alright, triple support.
Let's go.
It's like you never left.
To be fair, we were all...
also playing triple support in the early access stream.
Everywhere we go, you always see them.
Triple support.
All right, let's go.
All right, do your thing, Black Panther.
You have everything going for you.
Do your thing.
Do your thing!
Oh shit, here, you do your thing too.
We're anti- Wait, they're anti-dive.
I'm so confused, what the fuck is going on?
Like...
Like what is going on right now?
So many people should be dying right now.
Why are they still alive?
okay are they also going triple support because why is
nobody dying i think they're also going triple support guys
most likely yep they are i was like why is no one dying this
seems like this feels very triple supporting on the enemy
team too that's not fair What do you mean they also have
triple support?
That's not fair.
All right, goodbye.
Wait, unless?
Unless?
Where is he?
Maybe.
Oh, fuck it.
Let's go.
All right, rotating time!
Get ready for this.
the atom res soon guys oh no this is bad at you oh this is
bad please the atoms coming back damage this venom you
damage well it would be great i'm dead i would oh here you
go ready are you ready for it born again
Where is he?
Oh my god, he dies when I fall my god.
He dies when I get up.
Fuck it.
It's not worth playing.
A mantis.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna have to do pierce, actually.
I just don't know how to use this all.
I might just have to do pierce.
This might be the only way.
Okay.
Don't worry, I'm piercing!
I'm piercing, I'm giving pressure!
Pierce it!
There we go.
Look at that.
He's so cute.
I don't...
All right, get ready for...
Oh wait, at least I don't have a...
So I don't have to embarrass myself yet.
I don't have to...
to embarrass myself for now.
Oh, see, I told you.
This is the only reason to...
The Pierce is just too good.
Goodbye.
Where are you going?
Where are you?
going where i can swim away oh no i have all now oh no oh no
i don't know what to do with i have all don't do this to me
don't do this to me
maybe i'll never have to use it
it's okay as long oh my god where are you doing at him all
right two more fights two more fights i'm piercing
it's all right i'm piercing healing can't do anything there
you go i i ricocheted his him look at that i'm doing my job
oh my god
maybe oh what What if I just ate Adam?
I don't know where to put him.
Okay.
My team's dead.
It's okay.
I'm stalling.
Please.
Strange.
Get on.
I stalled as long as I could.
I stalled.
I mean, I, I did my job.
I did my job.
Oh, so many.
Thank you for giving us some to lime.
Thank you.
Where's the...
Wait, wait.
Nobody did...
Where was...
Why did the 1TP?
He's not even bad.
He's not even...
You have no excuse.
He's not even bad.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, it's my connecting thing.
I could have been using that.
I don't know.
don't think i had it so it's gonna be a long day for you i'm
in gmt i just finished my placements i know it's end of
season i just finished my placements on gm2 you're gonna
tell where where it's at right now
i forgot the team up they keep adding team ups every every
season it's a new team up I always... I just in the end.
Oh my god.
Why is he mad?
Why are you mad?
Please!
No!
Oh my god.
I literally...
I'm trying to sell fire away.
There we go.
No, please.
I can't have a noise complaint.
We're losing to that.
Oh my god, why are you mad?
Control me!
They're making you...
Oh my god, I don't even know where he's barking.
He's not even...
He's just barking in the living room, just to bark in the
living room.
Please, I don't want to get a fight.
You've been so good Why are you Oh my god he's got closer
Why did you get closer?
Please I haven't died yet I won't I won't deal with you Dad
please
No Please Oh my god Please I haven't died I won't do stuff I
won't
There we go!
Oh my god.
I mean, I can just...
I can just swim away.
I don't have to be here.
Don't have to be here.
Alright.
I mean, I'll take that.
Oh, it's okay.
All right.
All right, here we go.
What?
No, no.
Okay.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I'm back.
We're back.
We're back at it.
All right.
Guys, I think I'm figuring out, Jeff.
Wait!
Boom!
I remember the power-up!
Oh, shit.
Okay, I could just...
I remember the power-up.
There we go.
We're doing it.
I remember.
It was so good for so long.
Then he found out I had a sponsor.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Well, look at you.
Are you a superhero?
What can you do?
Alright, here we go.
I'll let you show me.
Doki always got the tired eyes.
Rivals does things to you.
I think I'm doing pretty well on Jeff, guys.
I think.
Oh, I say as I messed up that climb.
Guys, I think I'm doing pretty well on Jeff, guys.
I was doing pretty well.
I'm fucking leaving you.
You guys can stay over there if you want.
Alright.
You don't have a lever.
They're liars.
They try to give you a false sense of security.
Alright, here we go.
I think I'm getting...
better at Jeff guys now white fox is the my worst support
because she's fucking melee I just I just don't understand
melee I just there's just something about melee that I just
can't under can't process it I'm like why am I using my
fists to heal like we're that's stupid I should not have
fucking what How?
How did I get hit there?
I wasn't even in the circle!
What?
The Namor thing didn't even, like, was in my range.
Okay.
That's fine.
I have piercing heals.
It's fine.
We can pierce it all.
And our Spider-Man did.
And our...
We got a little, yeah we do.
I'm just gonna...
That's fine.
Look, I'm with everybody.
Alright.
I mean...
That's fine.
It's fine.
I thought I would get it.
This one looked so chappable.
She fucked up her cloak.
How did it miss?
Her cloak got fucked up.
And yet it still missed?
That doesn't...
Oh.
Oh, why?
Why did you freeze him?
I was gonna kill him!
Oh my god.
The Hulk freezing that actually was so bad.
I was gonna kill him.
Oh no, not born again.
Oh man, I've only had my ult there.
If only I had my ult there, you got it.
Maybe...
Oh, we see nine.
I see
Poke, thank you for the tier one So thank you, thank you
It's not me, it can't be me It can't be my fault Wait, wait
a minute, okay It can't be me
It's alright It's alright, it'll turn around It always turns
around turns around.
It always, it always, you just gotta lose one and two and
then, and then everything and then everything will be okay.
Sure.
Yeah, the ELO slingshot, as they say.
This is my time.
This is it.
This is where the slingshot starts.
It starts right here, right now.
here right now.
Uh...
Now, who am I going to ban it?
Exactly.
It was a diamond exactly.
Always blame the lowest rank.
And the lowest rank happened to be diamond.
You're so right.
Come back to diamond.
I've never... Okay.
I actually haven't been diamond in rivals in a long ass
time.
I think the last time I was in Diamond was season was it one
it was either season one or zero is season one or zero so
don't bring me back don't don't put me back there I can't I
cannot especially end of season oh my god because that means
they've played many games and they're still there
but I don't know but I don't know it's okay this is the
sling the sling shot starts now.
It starts now.
I believe.
This is it.
It's gotta believe.
Okay, they banned Cloak.
What about player?
Invis?
Or Rocket?
I don't even know.
I guess Invis, right?
She's still good.
Alright.
Oh yeah, let me show you guys the video that I was talking
about.
About the the cat with a voice condition it just it throws
you off like you don't expect it
here let me see if I can I'll play it oh wait we're let me
head head to the location first and then I'll play it and
then you guys can hear the meow meow literally sounds like
the cat from eugenics yes the cat with the super Super deep
meow.
Alright, here.
Uh.
Say hi.
Come on.
Okay, you can sort of hear it.
It's like, meow.
I don't have time to shoot.
Yeah, that was crazy.
Meow.
Oh, that was my bad.
Thank God I don't have my super strike right now because I
would definitely be fast-fingering a lot of shit.
Accidentally.
There you go.
Alright, fuck this.
Are you serious?
I fucked this dash up and you still didn't kill him.
There's no way.
Alright, nice.
I was gonna say it.
There's no way you didn't kill him after I fucked up his
dash, guys.
Oh my god.
Alright, it's fine.
We just keep backing up.
It's alright.
Alright, it's fine.
We just...
He is so healthy.
He is still alive.
I don't...
know how but he somehow lives those where's my where's my
Luna where does she go I don't know where my Luna sorry that
was my bad okay to be fair our Luna was like somersaulting
everywhere thank God I was in here thank God that's not me
right now thank god i'm on invis i don't think the luna
knows she's not she's not at the it's not season 7.5 luna
yet she is practicing though she's practicing for it
there we go then you get away when you get away she got like
she got like grab that's how Which is unfortunate.
Will she be fine?
You'll be fine.
You will be fine.
Don't worry, I got you.
They have Spider-Man all.
They have Black Panther out.
They have everything.
I'm a little bit worried.
They might have a lot of things going into this fight.
I do have...
Let's just hope...
There we go.
All right, I'm just gonna...
Yeah, I am a little bit of freedom, that guy that's just
chilling over there.
You're so healthy, you're so healthy.
Look at that.
Look at that team.
We trust each other.
We trust each other so much.
Look at us.
Who would have thought?
Look at that.
Look, if they're gonna play dive, they should have went,
they should have banned Invis.
I'm actually, I'm actually cucking their dive right now.
Alright, they still have a fucking spider medal.
I don't know what they're planning on.
I'm a little...
No!
Keep going!
Go invisible!
I used my jump!
It's okay, I can jump one more.
more.
I cannot jump on this.
The one time.
There's no way.
It's alright.
The hero is coming.
Do not worry.
Live.
Alright.
Don't worry, the hero is here.
The one time I went out of Invis 2.
I literally like get predicted oh my god oh my god I knew it
I was like it's you and me spider-man read you like a
fucking book fucking easiest read of my life into the Not
everyone can wear the mask.
Is that the Spider-Man?
That was his first ult, by the way.
That was...
He was like, don't worry, guys.
This ult is going to be crazy.
It was actually his first ult, too.
He's like, don't worry, everyone.
Watch this.
Unfortunately, we all watched.
Wow.
yes yes he held it for the entire four minutes i have not
seen him use that all once
all right who's the it was fizzle right all right we'll
avoid phase fizzle
guys this is still loosable guys guys this is still loosable
they did push They did still push pretty far.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, there's a spot at 1v1.
Who's winning?
Whoa, okay.
Alright, to be fair, there was no honor.
That was not a 1v1.
I will admit, we were not honorable at all.
Oh, I'm...
Sorry, he's still very slowed right now.
Why are you in my sphere?
You get slowed from that.
Alright, no, never mind.
This is Winnebill.
Oh, I missed it.
Alright, recharge.
Alright, who was?
I gotta avoid both their melee players.
Their little...
Don't really want them on my team.
Yay!
Now, how I... See, guys?
I told you the ELO slingshot.
Starts now.
I told you.
I told you, guys.
It's right here.
This is where I'll begin.
Our Spider-Man was pretty good.
I mean, better than the other Spider-Man.
That's for sure.
Alright, it was uh there you go hitch human oh yeah i love
this here it is end of season i'll give them that this is
end of season oh my god they went full dive and didn't do
anything that is pretty sad
the bar wasn't very high they yeah i mean yeah yeah they
they really did try They really, they, they, they try their,
their, their support had more damage than, than their
Spider-Man.
I mean, it's Spider-Man.
Spider-Man's not supposed to have a lot of damage.
You're supposed to just one shot, but it's still sad.
It's still a little sad.
At least there was a bar.
That's true.
Yeah, they couldn't dive this.
That's fucking right.
Right.
Oh,
yeah, the twirking emote.
All right, where's Jeff?
I forgot Jeff had one.
I thought that was a mod.
I didn't realize he had one.
I saw the mod version of it.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, I bought it.
I bought it.
I didn't realize.
It like it was just like a stream of consciousness.
I didn't even really heighten it.
It all blurs together at one point.
There we go.
That's right.
My industry plants.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
this emote.
One where he shakes his ass.
Yeah.
You see that?
The blind, the first Marvel arrivals, blind box.
And then people are like, oh my god, I can't wait to get my
favorite Marvel characters.
And it was literally like three, it was like Luna Snow.
I think it was like Luna Snow, Spider-Man, Strange, and then
Seven Jeffs.
And
It's just, and then it's like, Jeff in a, Jeff in his winter
outfit.
Normal, Jeff.
Jeff in the duck outfit.
Jeff in the, it's just, it's just, whoops all, Jeff.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Oh, it's fucking hilarious.
I was just like, oh my god, can't wait.
You get your favorite, your favorite rivals characters.
And it's like, Jeff, Jeff.
Jeff?
Or Jeff?
Manning tank bullet.
No one's playing it anyway.
Moon night?
What year is it?
Oh yeah, I can show you guys.
Alright.
The meow.
Wait.
This is Jack.
Mo.
a little deeper than most cats.
Hey, buddy.
Mo.
Meow.
That's kind of crazy.
Mo.
I thought it was AI at first, but apparently it's real.
How is this the first time I've heard a deep voice cat?
They actually exist.
Am I the only support here?
Well, alright.
Okay.
Alright, number five.
You and I.
You and I, number five.
Yeah!
Number five!
Always said it.
No!
That's a lie.
This one isn't edited.
The tweet I sent you guys wasn't.
Alright.
No aim time.
I already aimed on Invis.
Invis.
Now I get to chill.
Now I get to.
Now I get to go.
Phew!
it's always so oh no no two tanks let's go oh no supports
let's go it's just okay guys it's okay this is all you need
all right if i'm actually all right i'll go rocket don't
worry rocket one heal always works we portal it's okay i
didn't realize we portal the team didn't realize we portals.
Okay, maybe.
Alright, nice.
Alright, now I can put this.
Sorry, strange.
I have to destroy the res there.
You know, I'm surprised.
I'm glad we lived through that.
Oh, actually no, it would have been better if I was on Why
are we quite the oh wait my res I was like ha ha
What there's what are you doing?
Oh what am I doing
All right, I do want to swap off raccoon though I feel like
if I was on cloak this would be a little easier against the
dive.
This is a little bit too much I'm just a little guy.
Ten seconds.
Just a little, little guy.
Just a little guy.
Trying to make it work in this scary world.
Holy shit, there we have all.
Oh my god, how?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Unfortunately, I did have to reload.
No.
It's okay.
Me and the magic are still alive.
Oh, it's alright.
Me and the magic are still...
Oh, it's okay.
Magic is still alive.
It's...
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna swap.
I don't wanna deal with this anymore.
I mean, that magic stalled for, like, 80 years.
So good on her.
Oh, why is it all die?
Why?
I'm so tired.
All right, I'll save it.
I should not have used that.
I really shouldn't have.
Now I don't have...
Oh, we're not living that.
Oh, my God.
Why did our strange alt back there and not back here where
there's 20 people?
It needs more.
I need to save it.
I definitely need to save my right click.
I saw my straight like my furniture and I was like
What do you mean?
I was next to you What do you mean?
I was next to you And then you ran Where are you?
I was next to her.
I was next to her Why did she not look?
Why did she, like, held it?
More next to him.
Wait, but why did she hold it, though?
It's okay.
She'll use her out here.
Surely they'll use her out here.
There we go.
Or maybe I'll use a mile.
By the eye of Agumoto.
I'm not.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
You're welcome.
You are so...
Oh, it's not.
There you go.
I am next to you.
Alright.
again send it i think about twitch prime thank you thank you
all right now we have no support else and i'm pretty sure
they have the fox up i'm pretty sure which is not ideal at
all i have to save this for the dive i'm i just don't what i
mean i get it okay Oh, no.
No, no.
Why did everyone leave?
Why?
What's the song?
I, I, well...
I...
I can't even...
defend this I it was last fight what and then he went I I
girl he went I'm just like okay I have no friends in time in
fact I have more friends at higher you that I do here.
I need to be higher so I can actually play with my friends.
It's like GM, what is this GM 3 or 2?
I don't remember that.
I deranged, right?
One healer again.
Dumb.
Okay, the Punisher is on Luna.
I'm the low elo friend.
To be fair, I haven't been playing a lot of rivals.
I literally just finished my placements today.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to heal.
I need you to know I am...
I have not stopped left clicking.
I thought our Luna would Oh my god It's okay It's alright
It's alright our Luna is alive And we got two And then maybe
they won't push up With 1 HP
It's fine
Oh no Now they have Spider-Man Now we have to be scared
I'm trying not to get pulled right now.
I'm trying my best to not be in there.
There you go.
That's...
Oh my god.
Why is she over here?
How did she get there?
Oh my god.
Out of her little guts.
Let's see, we won the fight.
I just don't know how he was over there.
I turn around and I see her pummeled in the corner.
When she was next to me.
She was next to me.
She was.
I swear to God, I saw she was right there.
I don't know how she got there.
I need Lara Luna heal.
Like she needs to build her up.
So I'm not I'm trying not to
Sir I'm just hoping it she doesn't have all she doesn't have
all yet.
She doesn't have all yet Ah, she alts it now She alts it now
She alts it now
Why did she ult now?
Oh my god, that little chuckle from whoever it was from
around my team was like, wait, she ulted?
Even she was like, oh my.
Oh, I couldn't.
I'm so sad.
I had it.
If I...
Oh my god.
I even it even showed half the animation I can't believe it
it showed like point one second of the animation That's
unlucky Okay, so it's still winnable There's still hope In
the bleak of things there's still hope
There's still hope here.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Oh my god, there's still hope in this.
I told you, there's still hope.
It might seem bleak, but there's still hope.
All right, they're going to portal unless...
Yes!
There, I told you.
There is still hope, no matter what.
Not the next round.
The next round might be GG's.
It might be GG's.
Oh yeah, you're right.
That next Lunar Vault?
Oh my god, I can feel it.
I gotta let her build it though.
I can't do much.
I can beat Cloak.
Before you attack, get ready.
Yeah, yeah, the Luna.
Yeah, I know.
Couldn't have done it.
I couldn't have done the overtime without the Luna.
Oh, that's for sure.
That's it.
Yep.
Damn.
Who would have thought?
Without that Luna, there would have been no overtime.
You're so right.
The battle starts in five.
Like, Toki, what are you doing?
That Luna has more kills than you.
Oh my god.
All right, Luna, Luna, I hope you're gonna be building that
all in the front line by shooting them I hope that's what
you're planning on doing Luna
All right There Luna Luna Luna Oh, thank God for it.
Oh, my, my Luna is definitely carrying me.
My Luna could have done that without my Luna.
That's for sure.
I don't...
Why does she...
The thing is, if she didn't run away, it would be even
easier.
The fact that she was, like, running away.
It was like, what are you doing right now?
now please luna luna luna luna luna luna luna luna luna luna
the light always comes back she had all this she had all Did
she actually had him?
We would have actually won.
We could have won.
You know what's crazy?
We could have won if...
We actually could have won the first fight if our Luna just
ulted that.
I mean, we still won this fight, but we could have...
We could have...
had kept our ult chart.
Or kept our...
The percentage.
But silly me for thinking that...
Where is our Luna?
Luna!
I hope...
There you go.
Alright.
See, that's...
It's called zoning.
That's what I like to call in show business.
zoning up okay okay okay
all right
all right it's all right my Luna's building all and I need
him to build all that's all I need Luna Luna Luna just Just
build your all, Luna.
Luna.
Oh my god.
I swear to god, this Luna is building all so slow.
I, like, I don't know.
It just feels abnormally slower than it should.
Guys, guys, please.
Why are we pushed up?
I got it.
Alright.
Alright, I...
Alright, here we go.
We do have all...
We do...
Please.
Luna!
Wait, this Luna is actually so...
This Luna...
We don't have portal!
This...
Why didn't she help?
This Luna threw a three-year-old in a row.
Oh my god.
This Luna.
This actual Luna.
This actual...
I don't deserve to lose that game.
Oh my god.
Oh my
god.
Oh, it was that Luna.
Oh my god.
She was holding the thing was.
She kept holding the Luna all.
That guy.
That guy too.
She can react to the strange all.
You can react to the strange all so fast.
Bro, okay, I honestly, this is one of those games where I
feel like I definitely did not deserve to lose that game.
I didn't, I did, I actually, I did so much, I did so much
for my team in that one game.
That one game, I actually fucking, I actually reacted to
everything.
Like, fire.
Sentinel, thank you for...
Wait, I already said...
I've been fired.
You used Twitch frowning.
Thank you.
Oh my...
It was so winnable.
It was actually...
If she ulted the last three fights that we could have
ulted...
Oh my god.
I've never...
I...
I don't understand.
I need to know...
What is in that man's...
head what is in that guy's head when he's playing Luna what
was he thinking what were you thinking what what were the
voices telling you I need a know what did the voices say
just go pull down be closer to patty cake yeah Yeah, they're
like, shouldn't please be next to me so you can patty kick
together.
We will never know.
We will never know what those voices said.
Alright, my turn to play Luna Snow.
Honestly, there were no voices.
Honestly, fair.
I would not be surprised if there was just nothing.
Just nothing there.
It's all right.
It's okay.
I've avoided them.
Never again.
Alright, here we go.
It can't hurt me anymore.
I can only hurt myself as the new Luna Snow.
that Luna I can only hurt myself now now it's her turn to
yell at me oh my god he exploded I will have to say I don't
know if this is if it's like if anyone else if this happens
to anyone else but like there's so many team ups and they
change every fucking half season that I sometimes I just
forget I just forget my team ups because I'm always having
to remember team ups like it just happens to me a lot
because I'm just like oh yeah I have this team up because
there's just so many team ups oh no no no no
try oh it's no longer fun Whoops.
Oh shit, a golden kappa!
Yippee!
That's why people were like, use your team up.
I was like, oh yeah, I have that.
Please tell me we're destroying it.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I'm not hitting my snowflake.
It's fine, it's fine.
We are alive, we are alive, and it's fine.
And then we push up now.
And then we're going to have three, two, one.
There we go.
Please come.
She used her up.
Oh, fight side thingy with five gifts and subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Drake, thank you for the tier one subs.
Oh, no.
I will say if I was here, I would have used it earlier.
Like, the moment my ult was gone, you just pop it, because
it was a huge fight, and they were all, like, collapsing on
us.
I would have just used, I would just popped it right there.
There was no reason to hold it for so long.
This is why, like, it's, oh, it's so rough playing GM at the
end of season.
Because I have all these thoughts in my head.
Because I'm like, why aren't you doing this?
But, like, I can't blame them, because...
You know, please tell me where...
Please.
Oh my god.
Keep the tree- Oh, thank you guys!
Thank you!
Guys, don't judge me with that aim.
I haven't played- I've been- I've been on Cloak and Jagger
the last two games.
I'm hitting the heels though, I'm hitting the heels.
I said, no, no, you did not.
You did not see that.
Oh my god.
Poor.
Alright.
We were all just split up.
We were like, you're not getting me.
You can only get one person.
We're like, not today.
Not today, little shark.
Alright.
My freedoms are starting to drop, though.
Mike, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Taya, thank you for the tier one subs.
Ooh.
Ooh, they're going anti-dive now.
Oh.
Alright, it's fine.
You think they'll be okay?
Yeah, I was just gonna...
Not me!
There you go.
I said not me!
Alright, there is a mag right behind us if we would like to,
you know, kill him.
Yeah, there he is.
Woo!
Hey, he's still there.
He's still...
Hey, remember that bag behind us?
He's still there.
Like, are we...
Are we gonna do anything about this guy?
Oh, wait!
Oh, you just...
I'm starting out of that
bad guy.
My impasse actually left me there.
I swear...
Weird again!
That's crazy!
I can't- I thought- I thought we had something there.
What happened to PattyKick?
Okay, so it doesn't come back.
He threw it off the clip.
That is fine by me.
Me?
Oh!
Oh, oh!
That's unlucky.
I believed in the mag shield.
Uh, Urchin, thank you for the 150s.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, you should have let me fucking heal.
We are,
man.
I swear to God, if we're letting this...
Oh,
man.
Nice.
Aim bot, let's go.
I'm getting my revenge.
There we go.
Sean, thank you for the thousand biddies.
Thank you.
Thank you for the hundred biddies.
He's dead.
It's a smag.
It's been in our back, back line for like at least two
minutes.
and then my team like I don't know I managed to get the mag
like I got the mag like 1 3rd HP by myself and no one cared
no one cared I was like honey thank you for the 10 gift
itself thank you I really appreciate it thank you thank you
like what were they doing he's just sitting there and it's
not like I like I pinged him I pinged him so where is
everybody where did everyone go they were all notified
do I need to like send a DM at all at everyone and please
look at the mag at everyone But there is a mag in my back
line.
And then the healers left me to die.
The other healer just...
And I was right next to her!
Oh my god, that was a ping spike there.
That was wild.
It was like a series of unfortunate events all in one.
Like, I couldn't believe how many unfortunate circumstances
can happen.
in one go look at this mag look at this mag look at this mag
look at this mag oh my god we actually looked at him oh my
god there is hope there is hope people actually looked at
him
okay oh my god we just let them just let them zone us still
Oh my god, he was so low too.
I'm so sad.
He was so low.
Please, his shield is almost broken.
There we go.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, okay, nice.
It's whatever.
We'll never know what it is.
There we go.
We should be able to kill him.
Alright, I was gonna say, I hope she ults that.
Oh my god, please.
How are we still holding?
Oh my god.
How is the fuck?
Oh, here you go.
Take your snowflake.
thank you for the five gifted subs thank you thank you thank
you thank you everyone for the gifts guys i really
appreciate it thank you guys i love him here look at that
i'm a team player
there we go
boom truly that's not gonna eat me i don't even know who
that ate oh that ate all right oh Yeah, that ate two people.
I'm leaving.
Forward, thank you for the...
Five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, ten gifted subs.
Wait, are we... I'm not fucking...
I'm not fighting this.
There is no way...
Oh, whoops.
That should...
I could have hit that, actually.
Alright, there we go.
Let's go.
Whoops.
Yo, that was actually...
Don't worry!
I'm here!
Let's dance!
Beat him up!
There we go.
Nice.
Look at that.
I told you, the ELO slingshot.
The ELO slingshot is here.
I'm starting to believe.
I'm starting to believe, yes.
We're here.
We're here for it.
Alright, nice.
I'm happy I'm on a game with Doki.
Yay!
I'm not the real Doki.
And then I disappear.
I kill...
I kill his spirit.
And then I disappear.
what do you mean i just i just started playing i don't use
the bathroom you're back
no i'm back oh hey no no no hey hey hey
he's been so good for so long and then i got our sponsor and
he's back he's back he's like it's been so long it's been so
long since I get to interrupt her sponsor streams.
It's been...
It's been so long.
He's like, I'm back, baby.
He smells this.
I was like, you're getting paid?
What if you get paid less?
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Taya, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Eli and we all we all love you here thank you thank you I'm
just here to have a fun time I'm glad you guys enjoyed the
stream alright me and number nine clearly we're both we're
both gonna be playing support right number nine right you
and I we're gonna be a team also I don't know if I say thank
you to you already lazy thunder but think of a tier one sub
lazy and Some of you are thinking of the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Alright.
Thank you for the golden kappa train, guys.
Thank you for the raid train.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys for all the support.
Been a while since I streamed, yeah.
But to be fair, I've been, like, super fucking busy also.
Alright.
I don't know how much longer I'll be playing.
I didn't think I'd be at the For our mark, but here I am.
I don't know, something about rivals.
Something about my...
Or just competitive.
Something about competitive games.
Just gets me.
Just like...
Gets me going.
Gets me playing very long.
Alright.
Oh wait, cloak didn't get bad.
Alright guys.
Amy.
All right.
I did my one mandatory aiming session.
I did it.
Now I get to chill again.
Adam.
Okay.
All right.
Guys.
I guess we're not winning this game.
Oops.
Adam?
Well, I don't think you play Adam for... This is when a DPS
is forced to flex, and then they just pick Adam because
they're, like, he's a support.
Yeah, but then, next patch, season 7.5, now they have no
excuse to not play Luna.
They have no excuse.
Adam is good, but only in triple.
He doesn't...
Like, it doesn't help for double support or duo support.
Because then... Because we don't have enough heals now.
Wait.
I just don't have enough heals for this.
Like, I can't.
It's going to be very hard to sustain each other now.
Because me and Adam, he has two clicks.
Just...
Alright.
It's alright.
It's okay, right?
We're going to be five oh my god he's actually one he was
actually nice all right there we go there we go there we go
we're back where is he he's making me blind too
all right there you go okay that yeah yeah he's definitely
the item is the dps player i have to save my thing all right
Oh, I'll back away now.
I might have to use this.
Woo!
No!
I couldn't run away.
It was too late.
Oh my god, I didn't think the Iron Man had all.
I legit, like our team, our DPS didn't have all.
How the fuck was I supposed to think the Iron Man had all?
Don't worry.
The Adam can't res himself.
I knew it.
Alright, please.
Don't worry, freedom is...
How was I supposed to know?
The whole guy.
Sorry, I'm just gonna chill back here.
I'm just gonna chill back here.
Here we go.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna chill back here.
I feel so safe.
I'm just gonna chill back in my little cubbyhole.
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh my god, the Iron Man, where is he?
Oh, he was just beaming my back.
close no close there we go i don't know how this is working
but it's working and i'll take it oh they don't have a
strange let's go they have too much of an ego let's go he's
doing not terrible it's because he can aim so like his aim
is compensating for the fact that we have lack kills he's
just killing them before they kill us type deal but we're
i'm trying my best to pocket each we're both trying our best
to pocket each other and then you know what we're we're
trying all right he has iron metal i have cloak up i all he
don't have iron metal anymore is that an equivalent exchange
i don't know if it's i don't know if it's worth it but i
guess is either that or we both play chicken we play all
chicken just like the good old days with mag Your hog could
bubble you.
You could.
But this is also GM.
Like in Celestial, I can start to believe a little bit that
he would do it.
But this is GM.
So I don't know.
In Celestial, I might believe in that.
I mean, I'm trying to peel for him.
Wait, watch this.
See, alright, look.
It was worth it.
I got rid of the Iron Medal, guys.
And the Iron Medal, guys, I did it.
I did it.
He's gone now.
You're welcome, everybody.
You're welcome.
No need to thank me, everyone.
No need to thank me.
No need to...
No need...
Look at that.
No need to thank me.
Alright.
He's gonna...
We're gonna have...
I'm gonna need this...
Adam...
Just start doing something.
Oh shit, okay, that's fine.
Alright, he's blind now.
He's blind.
He can't do anything anymore to hurt me.
Alright, I have... I have Cloakle.
They have Iron Manle.
Alright guys, are you guys ready for it?
It's a bait.
I get rid of Iron Metal.
So my team doesn't have to worry about Iron Metal.
It's all planned.
Watch this.
I didn't realize there was another
Instructions unclear there's also a mag now They have a mag
Instructions were very much unclear They have a mag Alright
but that was Unlucky It's your double friend It's okay It's
okay guys the mag ult and I live nice it still works I lived
I lived yeah plan guys don't they don't have to worry about
mag ult now I sacrifice myself for the greater good it's
when all of according to plan.
Guys, I baited them.
Also, Shinigami, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Taga, thank you for the 100 videos.
Oh my god, you're serious?
Okay, that's fine.
I just need two more, three more points.
I ordered a flag for the exhibition, Dragoons.
Oh, I can't, that's not so cool.
That's so cool.
You should take pictures of it and then post it on Twitter
and tag us.
I love to see it.
won that game but who cares guys i sacrificed myself for the
team guys for the greater good i am a hero i i am a fucking
hero right now look at everybody's so high you know they
don't think you're so good because they are y'all you guys
think you're so good because you are really good
here what the fuck man what are you giggling about do you
think you want to be today what are you laughing about you
can't lay babies in your in your garage what
what the fuck i'm playing this background unless they black
band cloak what the fuck is going on i got that but you
brother look
open mic i mean it's convenient all right low key no one
plays low key anymore i i haven't seen a single low key at
all i mean i'm down with cloak band i won't band tank pool
No, I don't worry.
I remember the Luna's name.
Do not worry.
The Luna name was bed something.
I partially remember the Luna's name.
I remember the first three letters and that's enough.
That's enough remembering for me.
Oh, is she?
Oh, do you ever be...
I didn't know that with Mike.
I'm just going to mouth all the rest.
Oh, he didn't realize he was open, Mike.
Don't worry.
It's not like anybody's streamer or anything.
Yeah, I remember it has letters in it.
Alright.
I was going to say, why can't I play Press Confirm?
How much for a carry, Heavenly?
What's your rank right now?
Hello.
What is it?
A baddie's thing.
even to your one son thank you thank you flat okay sorry i'm
not laughing at your ring i'm just saying i don't have i'm
not laughing at your rank heavily i'm just i'm saying i
don't have an account that's flat right now i
i'm laughing because i think you're better than and it
caught me so off guard it caught me so off guard that i
didn't expect to hear plat and that's why i laughed true i
was like no way i believe oh my god my team that any my team
asked for a toll
Let's go triple DPS
It was just so surprising I was like I must be in range You
know I was like oh we're definitely in range
We patty cake we patty cake each other Okay, I can't patty
cake forever.
I can't oh my god oh my god you were supposed to heal me and
so we can yeah i had a feeling this was not gonna go well i
was like i saw her hitting the daredevil instead of healing
me but the whole thing about patty kick is that it's not a
one-man patty kick it is a team patty kick that's strange as
well The patty cake is supposed to be a two-man thing.
Oh, I thought...
Oh.
Alright.
Okay.
Whoa.
Save.
There you go.
I mean, I started the fight.
there we go look at that
oh my god we did we died we i mean okay i mean i guess we
could have died okay maybe we we definitely did not need
that one thing i know for sure we did not need the black
panther we we i think okay now i know that was overkill that
one was definitely overkill up that oh I turn around for one
second nobody pushing the cart Luna Luna I thought we had an
understanding here no oh my god he's he knows I'm here a
blind man knows I mean I got him came hooping back to me.
They have a strange out here.
Look for it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go.
Wait, are they running triple?
No, they're not.
Wait, they don't have a lot of heals there.
Volt angle, volt angle.
Oh, my.
Okay.
It's fine.
I have a...
I didn't want to use it because it was...
It was just not... I knew they were just gonna die
instantly.
Holy shit, all right.
You go...
You are so confident.
I'm trying to see if I should use it defensively or
aggressively.
I mean, it worked.
There we go.
It's fine.
I don't have to use it this way.
Oh my god Luna excuse me excuse
I'm just I
Looked at me this is why that's right you deserve to die
there Oh my god Luna looked at me She saw me one and she's
like, you're good.
She saw me's like, don't worry, you're good.
You're fine.
You're so healthy.
Literally, Max literally was just sneezing on me.
That's crazy, though.
The fact that he sneezed at me.
Oh, now, you know what?
I appreciate...
I appreciate the fact...
You live those...
Alright.
You live those, and I...
Yes.
I definitely do.
I hold my...
Alright.
I definitely...
live those
oh my god I don't believe I I don't think this team is it
yeah for what I'm surprised there are people that still play
blitz I'm so surprised that they still exist not gonna lie I
am oh my please I am you are you have heal reduction you
have heal reduction buddy
oh my god how is my luna mvp okay he must be like damaging
or some shit he's he must be farming it off of damage alone
because those game sense wise game sense wise it's very hard
to believe all right it has transformed this place is worth
a good look
I'm gonna let him draw.
That should be Mario.
I was a bit concerned with my team.
Don't know where I am!
Wait, where are you though?
What?
I have both quirks.
Sorry I said that too.
We were splashed.
Uh, no blocks on the fucking...
It's okay.
It's alright.
I'll have to let my Luna build up too.
I can't do anything about it.
Alright.
I hope that Luna is healing though.
All right Luna.
I'm letting you build up There it is 99
Holy nice for you.
Wow there you go This is bad though because they do have a
Oh my god, I'll never know where she is.
I'll never know where my Luna is
That was on me.
I should have just ran into the team.
I should have just ran.
I just, I got scared.
I got scared.
I thought he didn't see me, but he did.
I thought he didn't see me, but I forgot he's blind.
He can't see no one.
It's a top-notch team to win this one.
I'm not the type of me that's quietly into the background.
I forgot about that.
I forgot he doesn't see anyway
Oh, man You know, we push further than I expected I will say
that I did not expect us to hit that far I'm just glad we
push As far as we did
All right Back to, like, back to my death, I guess.
I still can't believe the mag, like, he didn't kill us.
I healed her.
She looked at me and then ran off.
But I healed her, though.
I gave her a second chance to live.
She saw me on the floor bleeding out.
And then she walked past me.
It'd be fine if she didn't see, but our eyes, our eyes
locked together.
I know she saw me.
Our heads were turned at the same angle.
Now remember here, Zach.
She died right after.
What?
Zach.
It's much better.
I hear him.
I hear the little...
Ding, ding, ding!
Hey, hey Luna, do you remember...
I'm gonna look at this.
I'm gonna...
I don't give up so easily.
Alright.
That's fine.
I swear to God, if she had missed, I swear to God.
He's on the hunt, guys.
He's on the hunt.
Oh my god.
He's okay.
Please.
I need you.
There's no way, if I had a snowflake, there's no way I died.
There's no, I don't understand how I died from that.
I still died.
She didn't die.
It's okay.
It's all right.
like me but i saw it this is it i can't i'm dead oh you see
me oh no oh no no okay we definitely did not need that
though we okay we do i hear him This place is worth a good
look.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go Hey, Luna, you wanted Luna?
I'm not peeling for you anymore.
I'm not peeling for her anymore.
I can't peel for her anymore.
I can't, I can't do this.
I'm not strong.
I'm not strong enough.
Eventually.
Get out of here.
I'm not strong enough anymore.
There you go.
Oh, where are you?
Okay.
Oh my god, we finally...
Raid boss down!
Raid boss is finally down, guys.
The raid boss is finally down.
We've killed him.
We killed.
He can bleed.
Guys, he can bleed.
He can actually bleed.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I hear him.
Bling!
Oh
Oh, thank God they got that well
Okay, oh you are so lucky.
Oh no Oh
Okay, there we go there we go I hear him I can hear him I
close my eyes and I hear him.
I feel like I'm the blind one
What the fuck?
Oh, bro, you gotta sit while solid, bro.
Damn.
Oh my god.
Don't, don't give me hope.
Don't give me hope right now.
Don't say that.
Oh my god.
What?
He's got...
The evil has been defeated.
No, he's got...
I don't...
Oh my god.
Oh no, I was so close.
Oh my god, do we have TP though?
Okay, I might get out here.
Look at it, look at it, look at it, look at it, come on,
come on, come on, come on, come Oh my god.
Oh my god.
The evo's been defeated.
We did not deserve to win that.
They're fucking...
Their double did so much.
He did so much.
He tried so hard.
He has 25 final points.
blows his team his team he did not deserve to lose that holy
he actually he actually was on a generational run with that
game he was like there's no way a win is a win oh my god
he's in my walls is oh my god i can't believe we survived
that he did he did his part his team unfortunately his team
his team unfortunately not so much like why did they swap
the storm there like holy shit the real dare double oh my
god the luna started healing me i really appreciate that i
didn't appreciate it in the And he was like you got this
right against the fucking dare double as like I do please
please ma'am I do not I do not got this and then and then
finally finally she was like oh you're dying the dare double
maybe I should start helping you thank god thank god she
noticed I'm just glad she figured it out before it was too
late oh I still got it though I still got it.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright, after all of that.
I don't want to aim today.
After that, I'm done aiming.
Sounds sad.
No, I'm fine.
I'm good.
Now, who am I gonna banish from this match?
Are you more than okay?
Yeah, it's like the best day ever.
Oh.
That's how I was in my life.
Let's see.
Sorry, I got work message.
Alright.
Oh.
I'm just happy that game was over.
The adrenaline rush is gone.
The...
I'm just glad.
I'm just glad it's fucking over.
And I'm free.
I'm free from that hell.
Truly was.
Why?
Okay.
Why would you make me try?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
It's not that I'm not trying.
But, I mean...
I was trying my fucking ass off.
Last game.
That last game.
But I...
I need a break.
I need...
I need to not aim right now.
I...
I would play Rocket if I didn't have a Jeff right now.
Actually, I could still make it work, but Cloak is just so
strong.
I just need...
I just need a chill.
Oh, no, it's this map.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, no.
Maybe I should just play Rocket.
I don't know.
I'm worried.
I'm going to alt.
And then, like, I just...
I went backwards.
Or I alt off the cliff.
Oh, no.
The one thing I wish rivals did have is win streaks.
I wish rivals have win streaks like other ranked games.
Just for consistently winning.
Because it just takes too long.
It takes too long to grind.
Three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Ow.
No.
Oh.
Hey That was pretty hey guys, that was pretty neat.
Hey yo your ass Are we so are we supposed to fight out here?
I don't even know man Nice
What?
Who's on me?
Oh shit.
I was like, who's on us?
I couldn't even tell.
Whoa!
Oh that's unlucky.
That's unlucky for me too.
They actually TP that.
Wow.
Alright.
Oh wait, we didn't ban Gambit.
Fuck.
I didn't even realize that.
Oh my god, wait, it's so far.
I just realized the point is so far.
It'll be fine, right?
T was almost not fine there.
I mean, I can...
Alright, let's see if I live this.
Woo!
There we go.
I should blind Blinded They're gonna that's right Blind
forever Look at that That was a good ass up.
Oh, no Oh shit
Hear me camera camera camera camera Who said that, dude?
My god.
That was very scary.
Why was nobody impressed on my team?
Why did no one said good job, good job, Cloak?
I just made a play of a lifetime.
Why did no be like, oh my good fade, Cloak?
Where is my, like, where is my positive reinforcement?
How am I supposed to have my ego boosted?
If I do fades, like, if I do plays like that,
So ungrateful Oh yeah, no, we're not living that But at
least I can get all charged Don't come in Oh
My god Maybe We plays in that Maybe I can't heal this
forever those so I need I don't know what that beats are
close what bro kill him can bubble you oh the the Punisher
in them I do it because he said he can bubble him but the
Punisher never said shit don't end there
we go I got you Punisher don't worry.
Don't worry, I got you.
All right, I chill now.
All right, let's go.
It's all right, I'm not reinforcing the cloak and dagger
stereotype right now.
That's a win.
It should be happy that...
Let's see I mean, we can kill her Alright There you go I go
push cart Me Okay, now everybody came back to push cart Guys
Somebody push cart And then it's like Everybody push cart
Oh Goodbye everyone Goodbye everyone Goodbye.
Goodbye.
There are Jeff lives.
Oh, he did.
I don't think our team is...
Nope.
Goodbye, team.
Yeah, our Jeff.
Ooh.
No, he's fine.
He's so healthy.
Yo, can you tell about Jeff go Gambit?
I'm not allowed, I'm sorry.
I'm not allowed.
He's not a...
Mommy doesn't let me play Gambit.
See, why couldn't that do that at one time?
Do that.
Okay, now I'm actually scared.
Alright, I hope our Jeff...
Hey, Jeff, look at me.
Jeff, look... Jeff, what?
Okay.
I don't think this is winnable, yes.
This team might be bad.
At least I don't have the aim.
It's the little things.
I'm just happy I don't have the aim.
Look at that fear.
That shadow thing will travel as far as they want.
What?
Oh They must be duoed or some shit.
What the fuck there was no comms about this play
Okay, I mean I'll take that I'll take that There we go There
we go.
They have cloak up though, so we better.
Oh, no, all right I love you Oh, I'll be here, I guess.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry.
We got you.
Where's our Jeff?
Oh, there he is.
I was like, where did he go?
Okay.
Alright.
I want to think that I cloaked Faded that.
I like to think that I did do it.
Alright.
Oh, I got a scan.
Oh, is that, like, the map special thing that just gives
walls to everybody?
Guys, it's my second time on this map, believe it or not.
I don't know.
Is that what this map does?
Ah, so everybody has walls.
So it can't be cheating if everybody's cheating.
Goodbye.
Ooh, you know what?
Good kite, everybody.
Good kite.
Nice kiting, guys.
Alright, now I don't know what to do here.
Now I don't know what to do.
I've kited as much as I could.
Oh, nice, nice kiting, guys.
Alright.
My turn.
That's right, mine!
Oh, wait.
Oh, hello.
I wonder why I wonder why they saw all those skills but did
he realize that half of those was because of me i don't
think he noticed that i don't think he noticed that i was i
was fired why did he throw me out wait time to switch things
up including which side you're on you'll need a top-notch
team to win this one But always at chance.
I don't know what I could do in that situation.
I don't know.
If we lose, is it his fault?
At this point, what do you even do?
What can you even do at that point?
Round two.
I wouldn't know the real power of the light force.
Yeah, I'm not.
because the other two flew.
He chucked me at Mach 7 into my fucking death.
Where do I go?
Oh, it's here.
What the fuck?
You actually, I guess, yeah.
Like, how do you defend this?
Like, I'm so confused.
How would you defend this area?
I
Don't think I should have used my right click there.
I got a little scared.
I like pink
I'm gonna do it here There you go I hope that oh that hit
somebody that did thank god
All right, it's so risky to be in cloak for him right now
Does that just scan us?
Like, what does the beeping do?
Oh, it does.
Surveillance mode.
I was going to say what...
Oh, my God.
It should have been...
I should have healed him.
I didn't think he would get pressured so hard.
How?
I don't even have walls yet.
It's not fair.
okay are we gonna yeah i was gonna say i hope we i hope all
right we all have we double support here i just wasn't sure
i wasn't sure if it was winnable i i got worried i saw so
many people people so low they do have invis also so we
don't have any support oh my god I don't even think oh this
is bad oh
my god oh my god no I couldn't get the fade there was so
much going on
There's too much, too much stuff.
Too many cooks.
Alright.
No, man, I wonder why.
I wonder what.
It's just hard, because we only have one defense level.
So it is pretty rough right now.
to use my cloak abilities i don't know if it's worth it
we're also giving them like a lot of free space though which
i don't like okay
i'll just
I hope they're going forward
Oh, we did not need that We did not Oh, my God We did not
need that, though It's fine I'm in my little safe
Did it disappear?
It disappeared.
You see?
It disappeared, yeah.
It disappeared.
Who would have thought?
It's got two more minutes of this health.
We kill that magic?
Is she still there?
Surely we can kill her.
She lives!
unlucky I feel like she has they have more DPS to kill us
than we do oh maybe we don't have to be careful if he's dead
okay all right oh my god okay I did not expect him to die
that fast though I'm just gonna be back here because they do
have strange all and I'm scared I am so scared oh my god
what is this fucking oh my gosh Jeff's I'll just say what is
this Jeff's statue
okay all right nice nice the cloak all did nothing because
everybody for some reason got off the cloak all that's what
I like to see okay I faded away.
I faded away.
I knew he was aiming for me.
Kill him, kill him.
I'll blow him off.
All right.
All right, I have all for last fight.
For last fight.
Here we go.
Daddy, daddy, daddy, daddy.
I'll block after you.
Are you sure I jump?
Oh my.
I'll block after you.
Oh, yo, why are we- Why are we all- I didn't think I died
that fast.
I didn't think I'd die that fast.
It worked every time.
Okay, I didn't know what happened to my chest, but I did not
think I died that fast.
That was my bad.
It was like, oh my god.
Goodbye.
I don't understand, but it has worked every other time.
Thank you, Armin.
Honest speed, last speed.
One of them, one of them.
One of them.
Oh, look at him.
He's on point.
Okay.
All right.
There he is.
Wait, they might portal.
They might portal.
And I'm...
Yeah!
Let's go!
Here we go.
We did it.
Finally, but I know I was just like, I was just thinking
like, it's fine.
It's fine.
I haven't been punished so far.
Ulting into a punishable.
It should be okay.
It is just...
I was finally punished.
I didn't know what was going on with Jeff, though.
I didn't know.
Yay!
I did.
I did win.
Yippee!
Oh.
Alright.
I think this is a good...
You know what?
I think this is a good time to call it.
Unless unless someone hits me up to duo.
I don't want to solo queue anymore.
I'm solo queued out.
I am solo queued out.
I think I told you the Elo slingshot.
I told you guys.
I told you.
We're positive now.
The Elo slingshot works.
Anyway, my name.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
I don't have an account.
in flat i have an account in bronze like i only have an
account in bronze or or my main because i haven't played on
my alt accounts in so long uh just because like i didn't
feel like i don't know i just i don't have time to play on
like alt accounts anymore uh anyway guys um i mean i could
try it what the fuck is erotic toward bjorn i don't know who
you are oh he was on my team last game i'm pretty sure he
was on my team last game all right let's look all right we
was on the game before too right oh he's like a hard flex
all right we judge we judge you diamond one
I don't know if this is some guy's alt account.
No, no, it's not.
Wait, actually?
Wait, actually.
Could be.
I can't tell.
I can't tell if this is some guy's alt account or not.
I can't tell anymore.
There's been too many seasons.
I've lost track.
Wait.
Anyway, guys.
I'm going to call it here.
That was fun.
Three were fun games.
Maybe next time.
I'll try and get an account in Platte.
Maybe next time I'll play.
I don't know if Heavenly's still here, but you are.
I'll try and get an account in Platte.
Or like gold, I guess.
I mean, it should be easy.
Bronze, like, you get a lot of points when you're in lower
Elo.
I remember.
It's like 60 plus points or some shit per win.
But next time, maybe.
Maybe I can get it for the new season.
Maybe I can find and get an account to Platte or Gold.
gold like that plat is plat is too long to climb well not
really it's just like a couple more games but i still low
effort 60 plus um if you're like hard carrying if you're
hard carrying and it's very noticeable in the game like
compared to everybody else you get like at least 50 plus
points per win like you can literally win like two games and
then like get up a tier if you're like in 100 points, I'm
pretty sure, right?
In bronze, it's like 100 points, and then the more the high
you get, the big points get lower, but you can easily get
like 50 to 100 points per win in the low E-low.
Yeah.
Anyway, guys, thank you all for watching.
If you're new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but I had a sponsor today on
Twitch for the early access with Marble Rivals.
That's why I was here.
Thank you all for sticking by and watching me come back to
play Rivals.
Because it has been a while.
Like I said, I did I've only done like, I just did, I just
finished my placements today.
I literally have not been playing.
And I just, I just like, look at this.
It's like March and then huge, and then like a couple, a
game or two every couple of days in March and April.
So it was nice.
It's nice to see that.
I still got it.
I still got it, guys.
I mean, I've been, I've been doing some generational plays
for my team in that Elo.
but anyway guys uh you want to support me oh yeah you want
to know whenever i stream on twitch please feel free to
follow me on uh twitter i usually tweet out when i'm
streaming on twitch if you want to support me via enemies i
do have a merch store uh i have several merch stuff going on
and it's a uh um and it's a great way to support me anyway
guys but yeah check me out on youtube that is my main
streaming platform uh no big no big no big announcement
tomorrow i know i tweet about i'm gonna tweet about i'm
gonna get a reply about it uh but because uh the to maybe
Tuesday, I think.
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posh, check it out, and
move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Thank you for all the raids, the bitties, the donations, the
subs.
Thank you guys so much.
I always appreciate the support.
Bye-bye, everyone.
Bye-bye.